you
you
all right welcome everybody we are just
moments literally moments away from
election results the March 10th it's
being called sort of the what's occult
mini Super Tuesday or Super Tuesday two
or mini super super mini I who knows
what it is in any case there's a bunch
of elections today and we are very very
close to getting results we are going to
be here for a while
we are expecting I mean listen I don't
know I'm sort of expecting all of the
results by 11 p.m. but we're already
hearing about some delays in Michigan
we're hearing about a bunch of different
things so so we'll have to wait and see
but I have made it no secret so to speak
that I believe it is going to be very
very good for Joe Biden tonight and I
will give you my delegate predictions
momentarily let's see if we have any
results now that it is 8:00 p.m. I mean
thank you to all of our public
broadcasting partners for providing us
with critical reporting on the ground in
some of these states on primary night
I'm joined now by Lisa de chardin thanks
for being with us
so Lisa what's it for a moment pull back
and talk about the state of the race of
the Democratic primary so it seems PBS
is not doing results right away we will
see if the Washington Post is and of
course we will be monitoring all sorts
of different results we have our
Politico dashboard which last week was
very very useful we have our New York
Times data we have Missouri numbers it
has been called for Biden no surprise I
anticipated that we are waiting on
numbers from Michigan and Mississippi
Missouri already called for Joseph R
Biden Jr and then we also have our Vox
data and let's see if Vox has any
information for us thus far looks like
nothing yet from from Vox but indeed we
do have a victory for Joseph R Biden Jr
in Missouri welcome to everybody if you
are just joining us we have a lot of
states that we will be going through
today as a quick reminder this is just
my opinion okay this is my prediction
for what we will see by the end of the
night
right now the numbers are let me refresh
and make sure this is still active and
zooming in a little bit for you guys
there we go that looks nice right now
depending where you look the lead is
around a hundred delegates according to
the Associated Press numbers Joe Biden
670 and Bernie 574 when I put this
together in the morning there were seven
fewer delegates counted I believe that
there will be a rough split in Idaho
maybe with Biden getting one or two
additional delegates I believe that in
Michigan it is going to be Biden I know
there's controversy about Michigan
Mississippi I believe has already been
called for Biden and I think it will be
huge there Missouri has been called for
Biden I have it 41:27 Washington will be
closed North Dakota will be closed and I
predict by the end of the night Biden
Biden will be ahead by roughly 144 but
as folks are saying both Missouri and
Mississippi have been called for Joseph
R Biden Jr realistically it is just so
lopsided particularly in Mississippi
where we see from the exit polls that
two-thirds of the vote is
african-american Bernie Sanders just
can't get black people to vote for him
Mississippi will likely be extremely
lopsided and Missouri slightly less so
but probably still a big win for Bernie
potentially even double digits and we
are going to have plenty of time to do
what I believe is an inevitable post
mortem on the Bernie Sanders campaign
and there's gonna be plenty of time but
just as a microcosm of just everything
going wrong for Bernie three days ago -
three days ago in Michigan at a rally in
Dearborn bernie was introduced by a
radical anti-semite Imam who believes
that Isis is actually connected to
Israel and I mean it's like you know
what what are we even doing here you
might as well just throw the entire
thing away so we're going to be
continuously watching that as well I do
want your participation here today a
couple of ways to do that if you're
watching on YouTube via super chat a
couple of super chats already coming in
and they will show up right here at the
bottom left a people who subscribe on
twitch your messages will show up right
up there
that top right blue rectangle for
example CBD 1 2 3 subscribed on Twitch
and said David thanks for all you do
love the channel beautiful plague of the
earth gave out to tier one community
subscriptions on Twitch Shane errs has
gifted another five subscriptions on
Twitch and we do now have a hype train
going over on Twitch so a lot happening
over there let me before I get to more
of the material that I have for you
today as we start to see the results
coming in Joe Biden has one Mississippi
and Missouri able to be called
immediately due to the overwhelming
margin of victory for Joseph R Biden Jr
over both Bernard Sanders and Tulsi who
is still running hey guys
Toole season third place in the sense
that no one else is running I believe
she does have a delegate or what was the
actual number Tulsi has two delegates
okay my apologies Tulsi has two
delegates very very good okay message is
coming in via super chat if you're just
joining us you can get in touch with me
if you're watching on YouTube via super
chat remember if you are indeed just
joining me hit those like and subscribe
buttons those buttons are free and last
on Super Tuesday so many people did it
that our stream was one of the most
recommended live results streams by
YouTube it really helps so please make
sure you like and subscribe
max says canvas in Michigan in a
majority black neighborhood Sunday
almost all leand Biden but seemed to
seriously reconsider when I discussed
health care plans very interesting John
McKinney oh sorry let me start reducing
the size of this as we go John McKinney
says do you think bill weld will run
third party once he loses the Republican
primary to trump given that he'll likely
take votes from Trump I actually don't
think weld will run third party but I
could be wrong
we will see it would be a delightful
gift Admiral beta's says sounds like
beta's yeah I know
hi David longtime viewer first-time
super chatter what do you think of the
possibility / risk that a Biden
presidency would like Obama's
- another Trump by the way I voted for
Bernie in Michigan I actually so the
Trump risk is not going to go away if
Bernie or Biden become President of the
United States I think that the Trump
risk will go away partially by removing
an incumbent Trump it's very difficult
to remove incumbent presidents and we're
going to have plenty plenty of time to
talk about that let me say thank you to
ayran bark 72 who subscribed with prime
and says I'm really just subbing to the
hair that's ok my my hair very much
appreciates that if you were just
joining us on Twitch make sure to follow
my channel we do already have some early
results both Missouri and Mississippi
have been called for Joe Biden those are
likely to be overwhelming victories for
Joe Biden actually you know the one
thing I did not have was we did have
polls so Missouri was Biden plus 30
on average let me see if I can zoom that
a little bit yeah there we go actually
that that's not so much better by didn't
leading by an average of 30 in Missouri
and it was able to be called instantly
when polls closed in Mississippi the
latest poll has Biden up 55 55 and again
black folks are not voting for Bernie
Sanders nearly 2/3 of the electorate in
Mississippi today black Americans and
indeed both states including Mississippi
called right away called right away
let's see if Politico has any updated
information they were very good last
week and the answer is no now I don't
even see anything with you is Politico
even showing us like if I click on
Mississippi on Politico they've called
it for Biden but they don't have any
vote in maybe they're not including
today's elections in this hmm that's
very weird I thought that Politico was
was going to be doing that but maybe
they aren't yeah I'm not seeing
that live live counter if somebody has a
different plot
dashboard that they think is good by all
means let me know we also have the Vox
one we have some early results in
Michigan Michigan so far is Biden plus
nine but this is based on 700 votes I
mean that this is completely worthless
at this point in time do we have any
data from Missouri Missouri again very
little of the vote counted so far and
Mississippi absolutely nothing counted
yet but remember it's so overwhelming in
Joe Biden's favor there that they were
able to call both of those states right
away welcome if you're joining us on
YouTube twitch or Facebook if you're
just joining us on YouTube please do me
a quick favor hit that like and
subscribe button we are trying to get
today a to 5,000 live viewers on YouTube
and you liking and subscribing is
extremely extremely helpful
okay people asking about a membership
goal today we do have this crazy
membership goal of one hundred and you
know what so last on Super Tuesday we
got 288 let's make the goal 88 or even
below it better let's make it 89 just to
match last week
Beatrice Barajas Mills has just grabbed
a membership at join pakman.com and his
new member number one today also Kim
Kaplan has signed up and his new member
number two so the the goal today is 89
89 which is high it's high but I believe
that we could conceivably do it okay
other super chats coming in let's see
here
wise California still only 94 percent
reporting it's been a week Utah's only
78 Colorado 89 all the Biden states hit
100 many days ago what is going on I
don't know the answer I don't know the
answer to that Jane womanpower says tell
viewers to like you beat me to it I did
Jane thank you very much appreciate that
Captain Spaulding says can Bernie run as
an independent in November absolutely he
could it would it would guarantee a
trump victory so that is one thing that
we would want to consider if that is
something that you're interested in let
me say thank you over on Twitch bill van
Bayer has cheered three hundred bits
parliament panda has subscribed with
prime and grungy dan grungy dan has also
sent one hundred bits which I very much
appreciate all that has happened so far
is that both Mississippi and Missouri
have been called for Joe Biden the polls
there were very very lopsided Biden
winning by fifty five in Mississippi and
I believe ultimately he will win double
digits in Missouri for sure and as you
see there we we have about ten percent
reporting in Missouri so far let's get
some updated numbers there if we can so
far we have in Missouri with about one
percent reporting Biden plus twenty
seven but it is very very early
Mississippi we have nothing yet and
Michigan numbers now have put Bernie
Sanders ahead again the polling in
Michigan was very weighed weighted
towards Joe Biden in fact let's look at
that Michigan polling cuz that is a key
state if Bernie wants to maintain any
even hypothetical shot here he must win
Michigan and he must win it by quite a
bit
the latest polls out of Michigan all
Biden you may remember that in 2016
Hillary Clinton was winning Michigan
polling by about twenty and Bernie won
it was by under one point but Bernie did
win this year we have Biden ranging from
anywhere from plus twelve to plus forty
one in Michigan but the results so far
very very early but they have Bernie
ahead by eleven points again under one
percent reporting under one percent
reporting delegate totals let's see if
there have been any changes made so far
nothing yet so we still have a Joe Biden
leading Bernie by right around 96
delegates depends on exactly which
numbers you look at this is from The
Associated Press The Associated Press so
far
super chats continue to come in Kimmy
Harris asks can burn
run as an independent in November oh
sorry I did that one already
Kimmy Harris asks watching from New
Zealand you have sucked me in David
never used super chat before glad to
have you
Danielle Beck says I voted in Missouri
today there were more than 10 candidates
listed on the ballot that had already
dropped no information given is the
standard or just my precinct its
standard there must have been 20 people
on the ballot when I voted here in
Massachusetts
Spencer Nair says voted Bernie in Idaho
potatoes are progressive Diana Brigid
says will the cool virus impact voter
turnout in seniors you know I heard that
it's conceivably possible I don't think
it's super likely but it but it's
conceivably possible that that will
happen
Stephen Perot says I'm Canadian what our
primaries primaries are when the parties
decide who do they want to be
represented by in the general election
in November a bunch of Democrats say
pick me pick me
democratic voters I guess independent
and Republicans as well in some states
that have open primaries say we want
this or that candidate to be the nominee
that candidate in November is on the
final ballot in all likelihood against
Donald Trump of course okay Jason
Aldridge asks do you think the DNC Biden
campaign have compelling dirt on Trump
saved for a well-timed release or leak
ala October Surprise etc I always love a
good October Surprise that goes in my
favor but I have no idea I mean it's
what we're just going to uh we're going
to have to wait wait and see if you're
just joining us once again you have not
missed that much yet other than two
states being called so far for Joseph R
Biden Jr Missouri where we have a Biden
lead so far it's sort of irrelevant
because it's been called the exit polls
are so lopsided Mississippi has been
called for Joe Biden no surprise 64% of
the electorate in Mississippi today wait
a second do I have the right there we go
64 percent of the Mississippi electorate
today African American and African
Americans have widely not voted for
Bernie Sanders Bernie getting only 16%
of the
black vote on Super Tuesday and Michigan
is is very very early on it's been
flipping back and forth between Bernie
and Sanders tulsi oh wait no that's
Bloomberg Wow Bloomberg dropped out and
he has more votes than tulsi so far
that's interesting but that may very
well change that certainly may may may
change and we are watching the numbers
come in in real time
let's see PBS not with too much the
washington post feed is presenting a lot
of data and math which which we very
very much like if you're just joining us
on twitch let me say thank you to a few
people fathom b has subscribed at Tier
one a luring Lord says any interesting
guests coming up on the show David would
love to see you interview Yanis
varoufakis would love to have Yanis on
we've got a bunch of great guests coming
up all of whose names escape me right
now because I'm very much sucked in to
these two these election results if
you're joining on youtube welcome we are
going to be here for a while please make
sure you hit that like button and that
subscribe button it really helps our
stream and we we are targeting 5,000
live viewers on the YouTube stream today
about halfway there right now and you
can of course get your name read and I
will say things that are really nice
about you if you grab a membership at
join pakman.com that's the most direct
way to support the streams it's the most
exciting way it's the most kosher way to
support the streams we have a goal of 89
tonight and you can get a 66% discount
with the code 2020 now as people sign up
see two people have signed up so far the
blue bar will creep across the screen
until it eventually explodes just off
the screen and destroys equipment in the
studio it's really crazy we have to file
an insurance claim every time it happens
because of the mass damage that is done
okay
other super chats that are coming in
here let's see here fawning girl says hi
David I've been watching secular talk
and Kyle kolinsky strikes me as a Bernie
or
just tweeting even if Biden gets the
nomination I won't vote for him what do
you think of : skis position I have no
knowledge other than what you're
claiming and is his position I believe
that both Bernie and Biden are better
than Trump so I'll vote for either of
them if they are the nominees because I
want to remove Donald Trump Joanne Apple
says sorry
Milly's boomers vote mostly vote-by-mail
okay Brandon the fish says voted Bernie
in a very old black area in Michigan
lots of Bernie support because it's also
heavily Union old GM workers and retiree
is very interesting we'll see if bernie
is buoyed by those numbers Matt Boni
says have you read glenn greenwald's
article titled democrats and their media
allies impugned Biden's cognitive
fitness now they feign outrage I have
not that is not an article I've read Mac
says make destiny a semi-regular guest
maybe the real-life channel says would
you say it's a good sign that they
haven't called Michigan automatically if
the polling was accurate would they have
called it all already yeah I think that
so there's Michigan may end up lopsided
in the results but they may not have
called it for two reasons number one the
polling was so wrong in 2016 the polling
had Bernie down 20 in 2016 and he won by
about half a point in 2016 so that is
going to make them hesitate to call
Michigan too early
there's also already some delays of
so-called irregularities or delayed
votes in Michigan so that's another
reason why we will probably see the
Michigan results take longer than they
might have in other cases but let's look
at the latest numbers Michigan now still
with only one percent reporting just
slightly and Biden's favor Missouri not
much coming in lately and Mississippi
with the first votes Abidin plus 73
right plus 73 in Mississippi brutal and
also Michael Bloomberg with more votes
than Tulsi despite the fact that
Bloomberg ended his campaign a week ago
always interesting when active
candidates loose to people who aren't
running anymore not not the most
exciting thing I'm guessing for the
candidates for the respective candidates
okay I'm getting the the requisite
messages that people are trying to sign
up on my website and the website is down
that sometimes happens as our website
hosting adjusts to the demand but no it
seems to be up it seems to be up it may
be slow but the website is absolutely
working right now for folks folks
looking to sign up let's see other super
chats that are coming in Thoreau fir
Beck says hey David I signed up to blink
Castagna advice and I can't tell you how
much I appreciate it
especially since I'm quarantined here in
Malta stay free yeah the the the cool
virus situation and that's what we're
calling it to avoid D monetization
because if I say what it's actually
called we get instantly demonetised the
cool virus situation listen if you say
David put together the worst possible
scenario I can put together a pretty
dystopian scenario if you say David put
together the best possible scenario I
can also put one together and that
includes the fact that a lot of
countries excuse me a lot of countries
have gotten it under control
China is rapidly reducing the infected
population there they are curing about a
thousand people a day so to speak a
thousand people a day are being
discharged or considered recovered
whereas they only have 20 to 60 new
cases a day Singapore has it under
control of course they are authoritarian
states they can do things that the
people simply would not accept here in
the US I'm cautiously optimistic the the
the death rate is what I believe the
death rate in the end will be well below
three point four the three point four is
heavily skewed towards early older
Chinese patients when China didn't yet
know what to do or what was going on a
lot of time was lost and they were they
skewed older if you look at the South
Korean death rate its 0.7 percent if you
look at the u.s. death rate even
considering how few people have been
tested there are likely thousands more
cases in the u.s. than what's being
reported even still the death rate in
the u.s. is only 0.3% so I think that
the death rate will be far lower than
the three point four percent but
this this has to be taken seriously this
has to be taken very very seriously
people are not able to get tested until
they've already according to some
protocols tested negative for other
things like flu and other infections we
need to be doing mass tests the waist
South Korea is basically the model
they've actually been doing it doing
doing it correctly let's see let's see
if we have any updates here from the
Washington Post because Jeremy you've
been looking at areas of strength for
Biden and Sanders coming out of that
Super Tuesday contests where do they do
well okay I don't like that the audio
and video is unsynched here on our
Washington Post feed so let me just
reset that it's a little weird when the
audio and video becomes so unsynched
people start to go crazy asking me to
fix it let's see the reason why the
Biden campaign got such a strength here
is because they do particularly well
against around two groups of voters the
first is African American voters and
this isn't much of a surprise especially
after the South Carolina primary but
it's been again it's a huge theme of the
campaign tonight and one of the reasons
why they did so well in Mississippi and
why we got an early race call in that
state now another group that the Biden
campaign does particularly well in is
older voters especially white
non-college educated voters and so this
group of voters is turning out in much
higher numbers than we anticipated for
the Biden campaign this year and it's
showing up in places like Missouri and
those are states where we expected by
him to do well but just not as well as
it appears that he's doing and yeah that
that's that that's basically what what
my analysis has been let's now get some
updated numbers Michigan the place that
is in play right now with two percent
reporting Biden is plus 15 in Michigan
very very early Michael Bloomberg with
one percent in Missouri Joe Biden of
course has one and with under one
percent reporting still holds a big lead
but not enough votes there to really
know much Mississippi also a massive
lead plus 75 and let's see if we
actually have let's see if we have
better numbers from Vox okay this is
with 5 percent reporting with 5 percent
reporting in Michigan Biden is plus 9
plus 9 that is that is good for Biden
but it is still early in
with there's not nothing reporting on
this website and then in Mississippi
still nothing so the the Michigan
numbers in coming out of Vox are useful
numbers to us because we are following
this this one very very closely as you
can see here we have a couple of Boerne
counties and then a lot of Joe Biden
counties so far and it's still very
early but we are going to continue
following those numbers and a check of
the delegates no updates thus far to the
delegate numbers let me say thank you on
twitch to Hadley Hadley has subscribed
with twitch prime if you're just joining
us on twitch make sure that you follow
our twitch channel we've been streaming
all sorts of different stuff these are
now updated Michigan numbers with 10%
less than 10% reporting okay that
doesn't really tell us if it's a full
ten but in any case the margin just 2%
based on less than 10% reporting in
Michigan so far let me say a huge thank
you to prawn JIT Raj who is new member
number three today at join pakman.com on
Super Tuesday we got 88 new members
which is why today's goal is 89 and
we're at 3 that's okay it's still early
you can sign up in mere seconds at join
pakman.com the coupon code 2020 now
saves you 66 percent the mushroom man
subscribed with prime and says simply
love the show keep doing you we plan to
we plan to Saylor Avon says I am a
reformed kolinsky fan he is Bernie or
bust
I left kolinsky not too long ago after
realizing how irresponsible and
conspiratorial he could be I would love
to hear more about that I don't watch
any shows that are like my show because
I do enough political stuff and reading
and then I want to watch other stuff I
want to watch you know concert videos
from bands I like and chess
instructional videos and and in infect
ologists reviewing infection data about
the cool virus really exciting stuff
I just quite frankly don't have the time
for
political youtubers deformity guaranteed
says this country this country is
screwed if Bern if Biden wins what are
your thoughts well I think we're more
screwed if Trump gets reelected which is
why if it is indeed bite in which there
is every indication it will be I will be
voting for Joe Biden let's see here
Jane womanpower says helping you to
remind people to LIKE and subscribe
yes indeed if you're just joining us on
YouTube please do hit that like button
and make sure to subscribe to my channel
both suggest to YouTube when you like
and subscribe you trigger trigger
YouTube to suggest this stream for
election results over other streams
which is a beautiful thing gr says pack
D Z it's gr what do you think of the
letter K is it used more or less than
enough I'm here for you but I feel like
you may prefer vodka not you I don't
know and I can't find out love G are
very very good
gr is known for these incoherent super
chats and we have an understanding that
I simply read them and then continue
Land Smith says hopefully you cover some
of the clips of the Dillahunty D'Souza
debate I haven't seen that yet but our
good friend of the show Matt Dillahunty
debated Dinesh D'Souza and I'm looking
forward to looking at that mic k says
became American in November my first
vote Bernie in Michigan
Bernie in Michigan and on that note
let's look at updated math and data from
Michigan now with 4% reporting in
Michigan Joseph R Biden Jr has stretched
his lead to 13 points with 4% reporting
in Missouri still under 1% reporting but
called for Biden in Mississippi 1%
reporting has already been called for
Joseph R Biden Jr quick reminder if
you're joining me this is my prediction
for where we will be at the end of the
night our starting numbers as of this
morning or at the top although a few
more delegates have been counted since
then seven or so and then these are the
numbers I predict for Idaho Michigan
Mississippi
Missouri Washington and North Dakota
that's north kids not south this is
where I believe we will be roughly
speaking by the end of the evening let
me say thank you to mid-june Aurore for
signing up with at which Prime
subscription ms-dos that brings back
memories I remember my ms-dos days
subscribed with Prime I very very much
appreciate that severely I want to say
thank you to Monique Smith Monique
you're a great American and that's me
making fun of Sean Hannity I don't
actually know that monique is American
and it doesn't matter Monique signed up
at join pakman.com and that is all that
matters and Monique is new member number
4 tonight
as we continue to await results from a
number of different states here oh she
loves you says call it the beer bug
instead of the you-know-what virus
that's an interesting idea the beer bug
maxing t'en 26 says hi from England
how will the spectacle of Biden versus
Trump affect center-left
opinions establishment failing again
Biden's mental health on display well
remember Trump's mental health Trump's
it's not a mental health it's cognitive
decline
Trump's cognition is not exactly what
you would call sharp right so I think
it's it's gonna be a big fight okay I'm
being told that Business Insider has
good numbers
Business Insider Michigan results let's
see 35 percent let's take a look here
what Michigan numbers do we have
[Music]
Michigan has 35 percent reporting with
Biden plus 10 so that's not good if this
is accurate it is it is very very bad
for Joe Biden and it would be Alma
almost callable depending on what the
what the split is if this is accurate
ladies and gentlemen if it is indeed a
10-point Biden lead in Michigan with 35
percent reporting if that lead doesn't
shrink okay now it's 39 percent
reporting in Michigan and now the lead
is still 10 so the way that this works
mathematically is if you have someone
with a 10
point lead when you are at forty percent
reporting you can know of the sixty
percent that's left how much needs to go
to Bernie for him to be able to tie and
at a certain point the numbers we'll get
to for example like okay if Biden's plus
ten with fifty five percent reporting
Bernie would need like sixty percent of
all of the remaining vote that's
insanely unlikely you can then at that
point call it for Biden but these
numbers are moving very quickly so let's
keep it here because this is really the
key race from the eight pm closings
Michigan Missouri and Mississippi we
knew we're gonna go big Lee for for Joe
Biden so we'll keep an eye on this with
39 percent reporting Biden is plus ten
so listen guys here's here's the the
here's the situation
with with Bernie Sanders and I've talked
about this before when the media said
Bernie has a ceiling of 15 they were
wrong when they said the ceiling is 20
they were wrong when they said the
ceiling was 30 they were wrong but it
genuinely does seem like Bernie may have
a ceiling of 35 to 38 among the
Democratic electorate the reality is if
you spend a lot of time on Twitter and
reddit the way that I do you can start
to think that the Democratic electorate
is far more into someone who calls
themselves a Democratic Socialist and
they're really into you can imagine that
the Democratic electorate is much more
willing to accept some of the toxic
people Bernie had around him including
the Imam who introduced him on Sunday
night or whatever you know the reality
is when you look at Missouri Democrats
when you look at North Florida Democrats
they're not gonna go for the guy who
calls himself a Democratic Socialist and
has the people around him that Bernie
has around him I agree with Bernie way
more than Biden on policy there's no
question about it but I'm not surprised
by these results you know a period and
there will be more time to do a post
mortem and I know a lot of people get
really mad at me when I say this stuff
but this is the reality and I think it
will be proven proven undeniably true
this doesn't mean Biden's a good
candidate it doesn't mean Biden's gonna
win in fact he very well may lose it
only means what it is that's all let me
say thanks to a few other new members
Eamonn Eamonn or Eamonn Eamonn Barrett
is new member number five
tonight thank you so much Liam Coogan is
new member number six tonight we do have
a absolutely insane coupon code which is
2020 now which will save you 66% off of
the membership of your choice at join
pakman.com if you are if you voted so
far even if it's not today if you voted
on Super Tuesday if you voted in Iowa
New Hampshire South Carolina if you
voted at all this primary let me know
where and for whom via super chat or
youtube subscription interested in in
seeing that last Super Tuesday it was
very very heavily weighted towards
Bernie the Michigan numbers have now
been corrected down to only 3% reporting
and this is exactly the type of weird
stuff that we were seeing predicted in
Michigan and it is indeed happening we
supposedly just had 40% reporting in
Michigan and now we have only 3%
reporting in Michigan so we don't really
know what on earth is happening in
Michigan over on the new york times
michigan is at 4% reporting and Biden is
plus 13 Missouri with under 1% reporting
Biden is Plus what is that 28 and in
Mississippi with one percent reporting
Biden is plus 74 Missouri and
Mississippi have been called for Joe
Biden Michigan is very very much in play
we now have eight percent reporting in
Michigan and Biden has gone up plus 10
plus 10 with 8 percent reporting out of
the state of Michigan if you're just
joining us we have had two calls
Mississippi and Missouri we are looking
at Michigan numbers and then we will
have more poll closings at the at the I
believe at the top of the hour although
maybe it's at the top of the next hour
now I'm now I'm unsure let's go back and
answer some Super chats and see what is
going on Jonathan McCartney sends a
super chat no message Joseph Dizzy's
says if it's Biden V Trump it is
essentially neoliberalism vs. fascism
while neoliberalism isn't good fascism
is worse
vote against neoliberalism will be a
vote for fascism in a Biden V Trump game
Jonathan McCartney sends another super
chat with no message a rich row Pathak
says since Trump knows so much about
germs and has the MIT gene was he for
warning about kovat 19 when he tweeted
cob feffy and asked people what he meant
maybe that is what he was telegraphing
there very good point Bryan Holaday says
obviously as progressives the Democratic
Party is to the right of us should we
support progressive Democrats or go
third party depends on what race you're
talking about and what the net effect is
likely to be from from that if you're
talking about a local race it may be
perfectly logical if you're talking
about the presidential race you may be
reelecting Trump
what matters is what are you comfortable
with are you comfortable reelecting
Trump in order to vote for someone third
party or right in someone who has lost
the primary or whatever the case may be
different people in my audience have
different perspectives on that and we
will have believe me we're gonna have
plenty of time to fight that out okay
Annunziata Cole oops sorry
he strolled past where was that a noon
Seattle Cole there it is only difference
between the u.s. and South Korea is
population United States has a 45% obese
population a pre-existing condition that
will make the rate for the coul virus
worse thanks David remember an inci
oughtta so far the death rate higher in
South Korea than in the United States
not that it's a contest it's tragic all
around
Jonathan McCartney says is there any way
Sanders can swing Joe Biden's platform
to the left during the DNC if he loses
the primary maybe so I don't plan to
vote for Biden if he doesn't make any
concessions to the Sanders camp listen
there are some very easy concessions for
Joe Biden to make on health care you
know why because Medicare for all is not
going to get passed between 2020 and
2022
Oh 2021 in 2023 I know some of my
audience loses their [ __ ] every time I
say it but that's the reality so if I
were Biden once he wraps this thing up
which which is all but a foregone
lucien Biden should say I have spoken to
Bernie here are the tweaks I'm going to
make to my health care plan to be better
to be more like Bernie's it's no risk
it's not passing right because you've
got even most most Democrats in the
Senate would not even vote for it so I
think Biden should do that I would like
to see him do that let me say thank you
to some new members at T n Bhutto is new
member number seven this evening thank
you etienne Joe Kirsch is new member
number eight tonight at join pakman.com
the goal is 89 new members why 89 it's a
weird number the reason is that we had
88 on Super Tuesday so we're trying to
best that if you are just joining us so
far we have calls from Missouri and that
was weird don't like everything just
blacked out for a second hope my whole
systems not falling we have calls from
Missouri and Mississippi we have data
and math coming in from Michigan so far
if you're just joining us on YouTube I
ask you with total humility and peace
and love to hit that like button and
certainly hit the subscribe button very
much appreciated over on Twitch thank
you to laughy TX for subscribing with
prime Sigma Y has subscribed with prime
Big Al 2019 has subscribed with prime
with the message yay oh now we're
getting to the weird usernames Lord baby
feet has subscribed with prime Mick
britches has subscribed with prime poop
stain c'mon guys has subscribed with
prime soubise zero-five-zero
has subscribed as has Barthel Barthel
has also subscribed with with twitch
prime joseph van Scoy says we need to
stop assuming that this must be DNC
intervention we lost it's just that
simple in times of crisis it is human
nature to go with the safe option think
Jimmy Carter after Nixon yeah I mean
let's actually look let me see if I
find a popular vote here it is you know
it's really important to understand that
when Joe Biden has almost let me
actually zoom this this is hard to see
here when Joe Biden has and let's let's
go the other way and zoom in when Joe
Biden has nearly a million more votes
than Bernie Sanders you can't just say
it was stolen by the DNC there's no
doubt that the strategic timing of Pete
dropping out and Amy dropping out and
Bloomberg dropping out of course it's
strategy to help Joe Biden there's no
question but Biden did get a million
more votes than Sanders so far and we'll
see as the numbers commit come in in
Michigan Mississippi Missouri later
North Dakota and Washington as well we
will see what what that lead is listen
guys I think that Bernie has a lot of
the right ideas but he is a candidate
that a lot of people are not interested
in voting for and we are seeing that
here firsthand and it is difficult for
the progressive movement there's no
question about that I also want to say
thank you to a goodman jones for the
twitch prime sub AC has again gifted
some subscriptions thank you
bovis or has subscribed Mexican GRA DOS
has subscribed and foofy dumplings has
subscribed as well k WB asks an off
topic question as the numbers roll in
where do you prefer for chess video /
practice well for practice ly chess has
a whole bunch of free puzzles lessons
all sorts of stuff in terms of videos
there's a lot of great people that are
instructional Eric Rosen who I've taken
lessons with is great on YouTube follow
him tell him David Pakman sent you
follow him on Twitter to these chest
streamers that David Pakman sent you
Eric Rosen's great on twitch and YouTube
John Bartholomew is very instructive and
and really really good more sort of like
fun streamers whose games I watch but
they're less instructive Hikaru Nakamura
Ben Ben I forgot his laws Ben goldstein
no Ben what is
Ben's last name now I'm forgetting it
people know Ben the the chest streamer
what's his last name
someone's going to tell me it's a
Feingold find that Goldstein find gold
yeah Ben Feingold is also also really
really good let's get an update on the
vote totals that we have so far three
states right now that we are watching
Missouri Joe Biden has one and
Mississippi Joe Biden has one Michigan
is very much in play with 11 percent
reporting Joe Biden is ahead by 10
points over on Business Insider they
claim that with 27 percent reporting Joe
Biden is ahead by 12 so two competing
sets of numbers here and they continue
to come in very good giant squid says
what do you feel are the chances of a
true progressive party starting up
independent of the democratic party do
you think America will ever accept a
third national political party or is the
two-party garbage there for good two
things two primary things need to change
for a third party to really have a
serious serious shot number one you got
a fixed campaign finance for as long as
the two political parties have this
outsized amount of money and the bully
pulpit essentially you won't see third
parties take control nationally or have
serious influence nationally number two
if you had some kind of single transfers
transferable vote system that would also
be very good it would let people support
third parties without a possible spoiler
effect I would like love to see both
morph Kogan's says business and say okay
we already saw that inconsolable sends
$100 super chat the biggest super chat
of the evening thank you saying the
prevailing narrative and left-leaning
communities is that Biden is no better
than Trump that Sanders should run third
party and that it's better to burn
things down then vote for Biden how much
of this do you think is noise and empty
threats I don't know that it's empty
threats what I what I would ask is does
anyone have an example of when burn it
all down has gotten us what we wanted in
the longer term I've looked and I've not
really been able to find one when I look
at the reforms if I look at the
progressive
reforms of the 1920s in the United
States they didn't come from burning it
all down when I look at the reforms of
for example the New Deal in the FDR era
it didn't come from burning it all down
when you look at the 60s the Civil
Rights Act and the civil rights era I
didn't see it coming from burn it all
down some people are saying well what
about the American Revolution becoming
independent of the the of England I
don't think is analogous really to what
it is that we're talking about unless
people are talking about secession or
something like that so that that's uh
that's my my take as of right now I'm
glad to be proven wrong as always open
to new ideas let me say thank you and
welcome to Scott Phillips Scott Phillips
this new member number nine this evening
really appreciate that and appreciate
the support also want to say good
evening and welcome to Michael Pope who
is new member number ten tonight Michael
Pope has signed up at join pakman.com
the goal is 89 we are at 10 so feel free
to add your name so to speak I'm
realizing that super chats are blocking
some of these numbers at the bottom of
the screen there we go my my apologies
there my friends my apologies there
other super chats coming in liam Jaros
says do you think we could make all
college free well we we can do it if we
pay for it and it wouldn't be all
college it would be state universities
and and colleges and it's not just you
sign up and go right this is something
important to understand about free
college it's not you just fill out your
name and now you've been accepted you
still have to get in if you get in you
go tuition free on the basis of of the
programs that many different candidates
have suggested as far as that goes
Kimmy Harris says why can't you talk
about it as coronavirus I don't care
about mentioning it here but on our
uploaded videos we're not saying it
YouTube is flatly d monetizing all
coronavirus content calling it a
sensitive current event and so we've had
to find other ways to talk about it
sometimes I'll refer to it as the
infection sometimes I'll call it the
cool virus people have
suggested the the beer bug Corona right
people understand what I'm saying that's
why
Rolando says yo PAC Diez where's Patrick
I don't know he's probably at home or at
jujitsu class or something like that
Rasmus haymaker sends a super chat sky
bucks says bababooey bababooey aaron
Hamrick says how does a race get called
with less than 1% of the vote reported
because the exit polls are so lopsided
when the exit polls are so lopsided you
can you can call it exit polls are very
accurate generally speaking
Michael posy says it's missourah so car
says electoral college change ever tired
of a worthless vote let the net look up
the NPV I see national popular vote
interstate compact that is the fastest
way to get to effectively a national
popular vote and I and I encourage you
to check it out let me say thank you and
welcome to some people over on Twitch
Sean H has subscribed what what a melons
has subscribed with prime and in your
groove has subscribed with twitch prime
as well at the top of the hour we will
do another deep dive into all of the
numbers from this evening so far
Missouri and Mississippi have been
called for Joseph R Biden Jr
and Michigan is in play most recently
we'll just look at Michigan real quick
most recently Michigan with a lead for
Biden with 27 percent reporting Joe
Biden plus 11 in Michigan right now the
New York Times has the numbers with 13
percent reporting as plus just under 11
for Joe Biden right now that's that's
where we are let me say thank you to a
very special viewer today Mike Kingma
Mike Kingma is new member number 11 at
join pakman.com as votes continue to be
counted Jimmy Deline says what if
anything could tank Biden at the debate
it would have to be you know Biden
having such a such such a cognitive
meltdown
that that that people say we that he
loses all the vote I mean it's
extraordinarily unlikely it was
announced today that as a result of the
coul virus there will be no audience on
the March 15
debate no audience at all it will be an
empty room that Bernie and Joe will be
debating in front of for four reasons of
preventing contagion and trying to shut
the whole thing down
Lance Smith says the full debate hasn't
been published yet but they published
clips on transgender issues and climate
change on the Matt Dillahunty Dinesh
D'Souza debate on YouTube very good
terry james says if biden is the nominee
the only way he'll beat Trump is if the
economy goes south I'll be quite frank
with you Terry I think the only way
either Bernie or Biden beat Trump is if
the perception of the economy is that
it's not good in November if the
perception of the economy is good in
November it's very hard to knock off an
incumbent president and that that's just
a reality gr says don't believe in
people we have no truth it's heart
people my super chat is understood by
all Pakman is using his talent don't be
fooled love gr almost Trump like in a
way inconsolable says PS thanks for
pushing back against dangerous rhetoric
and encouraging reasonable discussion my
pleasure
mr. Gonzalez says if the media coverage
of the Democrats race was honest about
policies do you still believe Bernie
would have that 35% or so cap I don't
know I don't know I'd have to think
about that Adam the D whoops that
happens when a bunch of super chats come
in at once it just Scrolls past Adam the
D says you think Bernie as Joe's VP as
possible if he contests no I don't
believe Joe is going to have Bernie as
his VP gr says what's happening in
Michigan party at G ARS place G Colin
says if Biden wins the primary does it
in your view wound the progressive
movement I feel like after eight years
of Trump everyone will vote for the
Democrat regardless if they're a
centrist what long-term effects the
predict I've said before it'll be
terrible for the country but it would
might be best for the progressive
movement for Biden to be the nominee and
then lose okay
terrible for the country people will die
as a result of it speaking of death
let's listen to the latest briefing from
Mike Pence best decision going forward
vice president pence talking today I
want to talk about the political
implications of that but first yes okay
we missed it we missed it unfortunately
let's see here nicole says diss votes
with this vote for Joe equaled DNC when
will giving in end if we not now how can
the Left be taken seriously on twitch
she didn't say my username dizzy boo be
boo Russia yeah I don't see that on
twitch I apologize I see the anonymous
grifter who has gifted a subscription to
Hillary Clinton on twitch but i don't
see dizzy boo be boo russia I'm not sure
I understand your question unfortunately
I apologize Nicole Kevin Dunham says
voted for Bernie in Michigan
Joseph said agathi says hot take on
quarantine National Guard deployment
IIIi think that you know the things that
China and Singapore have done to get the
cool virus under control I just don't
think that they would be accepted here
in the United States the deployment of
the National Guard I I don't really see
it as a kind of militarization I don't I
don't see it that way I think it's just
scrambling to appear as though they're
doing something when they're doing
barely anything at all if today Quincy
vigil says if today plays out as
expected do you think it will do more
harm than good if Bernie stays in the
race for the long haul any incentive to
stay and we'll listen
but if Bernie goes down more today he is
gonna get crushed next week because if
you look at the polls for next week let
me pull it up here if you look at
Florida and I want to keep the popular
vote up here because now Joe Biden has
gone up by almost a full million votes
if you look at if this is the right view
yes it is okay if you look at Florida
you know Biden's plus 42
next Tuesday Bernie is going to get
absolutely destroyed so there is a
question of whether Bernie should stay
in through March 17th in order to get
more delegates to have more negotiating
power maybe as we get closer to the
convention or whether Bernie should get
out to avoid losing potentially by 50
points in Florida with with more than
200 delegates at stake in Florida it
would it maybe an embarrassment for
Bernie too to lose that badly in Florida
but it's up to him to decide Erin Phelps
says what happens if Jo is found unfit
to be President
nothing Trump's unfit and he's been
president for three years Michael Lopez
says will Trump betray Pence and blame
him for corona yep Pence may be getting
set up as the fall guy for sure John
Cain says would Warren endorsement have
made a difference tonight thanks I don't
believe so I think even with a Warren
endorsement that maybe gets 60% of her
support to Bernie and 40% to Biden and
that that would simply not be enough in
a lot of states incredible TV says
billion as healthcare cuber
let's go Bernie Joe Rader says long
multi hour wait student voting lines in
Michigan like California Alexander says
you're awesome David thanks for being
unbiased Christopher hatch says when
Trump denigrates naysayers during
rallies that's him being on an him being
an the unpolished
when Biden tells a voter they're full of
s that's deranged listen when some gun
nut confronted Biden today and Biden
went off on the guy I don't I'm not I'm
not bothered by what Biden did he was
aggressive yeah he was high-energy
people say he's low-energy then he goes
crazy on a voter who accuses him of
having a position he doesn't have on
guns Trump attacks him III just don't
care about that I don't really bothered
by that and listen he wasn't when Trump
starts talking about my african-american
Mexican judge are you Mexican stuff like
that that's very different than when a
guy comes up to Biden attacks him during
a site visit and Biden goes you're full
of [ __ ] okay
I mean that's Biden's position I have a
hard time getting too broken up about
the
Biden did threaten to slap them as some
people are pointing out that I'm less
big on I'm less big on slap threats we
are five minutes away from the top of
the hour we will review all of the
results at that time so far Missouri and
Mississippi have been called for Joseph
R Biden Jr I have a bunch of people to
welcome we have a goal of 89 new website
members tonight at join pakman.com
number 12 is Lynn McCarthy Abbott Lynn
thank you so much I appreciate that
Ryan ramai is new member
uh that was weird what happened there I
must have hit some very strange button
Ryan ramai is new member number 13
tonight Jeff Morrison is new member
number 14 tonight Sean Hastings is new
number new member number 15 tonight Sean
has signed up for what we called the big
boy on our website the 480 dollar a year
membership that's the biggest membership
we have Sean thank you I so appreciate
your support and you signing up at the
480 dollar level I also want to say
thank you to Angelica Niblick who is new
member number 16 tonight one six the big
one six at at join pakman.com justin
haddock love haddock haddock justin
haddock asks is the climate screwed well
it's a little more screwed every day
that Donald Trump is president that we
know Jane womanpower says my darling
viewers like and subscribe my lovey's
yes if you are just joining us over on
youtube please hit that like button and
then absolutely destroy the subscribe
button like and subscribe is free and it
really does boost our stream in
YouTube's algorithm and we very much
appreciate that make sure to LIKE and
subscribe we we love it we absolutely
love it Joseph Dinsey says easiest way
to get third parties get rid of
primaries if the primarily if the party
leadership decides candidates then the
voters will not have to make false
consensus primaries don't exist in other
democracies that's an interesting idea
Eamonn Barrett says hey David loved the
show do you think if Bernie had ran as a
social democrat he might have fared
better I've been saying for years
why is Bernie Sanders calling himself a
Democratic Socialist his policies are
socially Democratic even if socialism is
viewed less negatively now than it has
been in a very long time I don't see a
net advantage to calling himself that
okay let's see what Washington Post
updates there are at this
oh there are none okay we are going at
the top of the hour to actually let's do
it now let's update the numbers first
from the washing from the New York Times
Missouri already called for Joe Biden
only two percent reporting and Biden is
up 26 Mississippi has been called for
Joe Biden with five percent reporting
Biden is up is that 56 points a very
very big lead very I'm sorry no 66
points 66 points in Mississippi and then
Michigan the big contest right now with
17 percent reporting Joe Biden up 11 up
11 in Michigan with 17 percent reporting
let's take a look over at the Business
Insider numbers they have more out of
Michigan Business Insider claims to have
30 percent reporting with 30 percent
reporting they say that Biden is also
plus 11 now let me take a look at the
vote totals so I'm curious about
something 295 and 236 360 okay so they
do have a in in actual vote numbers they
have much much more that's where we are
right now in terms of delegates we have
seen an update Joe Biden has now gone
ahead by 116 delegates now as a reminder
folks this was my prediction at the
start of the night okay at the start of
the well this morning anyway
there was a 91 delegate lead for Biden
my prediction which I made this morning
is that by the end of tonight Biden will
be plus 144 so I'm predicting an
acceleration of 53 delegates for Joe
Biden so far the lead has gone from 91
to 116 so we're almost half way quite
frankly to two to the numbers that I
predicted earlier today we have PBS also
with numbers coming in PBS with 18
percent reporting has Biden plus 10
roughly in Michigan and it looks like
everybody is doing their top of the hour
resets at this point in time
let's see what they have going on on the
Washington Post I am going to do a water
refill and then we will be right back
not going to be there standing up for
the working class you want a nominee
who's a Democrat a Democrat let's win on
Tuesday let's win the Democratic
nomination let's transform this country
a look at the Gateway Arch in st. Louis
Missouri where Joe Biden is having a
good night well it's now just after nine
o'clock here on the East Coast and we
have big news already the Washington
Post is projecting that Joe Biden will
win Mississippi that's based on exit
polling
we're also projecting that Joe Biden
will win Missouri and that's based on
early exit surveys let's take a look at
Michigan where it is still too early to
call Joe Biden has a lead at this hour
with about 23% of the reporting Jeremy
Bowers is standing by now at their
election insights team so let's go to
Jeremy okay zoom in on Michigan for us
what county should we be keeping an eye
on Jeremy yeah absolutely Libby you know
the story of Michigan tonight is one of
strange Biden strengths in places where
Sanders did so very well in 2016 let's
take a look here now you can see that
the state here is pockmarked with little
Bernie Sanders wins
now the 2016 version of this map showed
Sanders all across the middle of the
state and the almost the entire Upper
Peninsula now the deal is there aren't a
ton of voters in many of these counties
there are only few places where they're
actually a large number of votes and one
of those counties Wayne County which is
where Detroit is will be probably the
last one that we get counted tonight and
it's also a place where Joe Biden is
going to do very well so looking at this
map right now I'm already seeing a
difficult road ahead for the Sanders
campaign in the state I'd like to show
you a handful of counties that
illustrate just how rough a night the
Sanders campaign is having first let's
take a look at some places where the
Sanders campaign is winning right let's
take a look at Kalamazoo now Kalamazoo
County is home to the city of Kalamazoo
and it's a place where there are
actually a relatively large number of
voters Sanders won this county by almost
23
points in 2016 and he's only barely
holding off Biden here by about two
points tonight and that's with 94
percent of the vote reporting so it's
not like there's a ton of votes
outstanding that are left for the
Sanders campaign to pick up now let's
take a look at another place Grand
Traverse County which is further north
in this in the state this is another
place where the Sanders campaign did
exceedingly well in 2016 and now the
margin is down to about three points and
this is really the story of the night
the Biden campaign is winning blowouts
in a handful of places and the Sanders
campaign even in the places where
they're winning they're only winning by
just a little bit and those margins are
gonna be important especially in a state
like Michigan where Sanders only barely
eked out a win in 2016 now there's one
last thing I'd like to show you about
the state tonight and that is Oakland
County it's a suburb of Detroit and it's
a place where Hillary Clinton had a
rough time she won the county in 2016
but she won it by only she only 192
thousand votes there's 25 percent
reporting right now and Biden has a
hundred and four thousand votes already
in the county this is a shocking number
and he's probably going to get more as
the night goes on again this is a
Detroit suburb it's a place where he
should be expected to do particularly
well now those three counties sort of
illustrate what we're seeing in the
state of Michigan and really brought her
trends for both of the campaign's Libby
okay well there was some confusion about
Michigan reporting earlier this evening
Jeremy can you clear that up for us yeah
absolutely
earlier tonight there had been some
reports that Michigan was going to have
trouble getting us results here on
election night but it looks like the
what's actually happening it's just that
we're going to have delays in some
further out counties and in some places
where there are a large number of
absentee and early votes that were sent
in now those results are not
insignificant but they also aren't going
to be so material that we won't be able
to talk about the state tonight we're
gonna have plenty of results to look at
and we should even have some delegate
estimates but it's possible the state
won't be a hundred percent reporting
until probably tomorrow afternoon Libya
right all right thanks so much Jeremy
I'd like to welcome my guests this hour
here in the studio national political
reporter at James Holman senior
political David Weigel it's Erin Blake
hi Erin welcome and Dave Wagle national
political reporter fresh off the
campaign trail guys I'm trying to do my
social distancing
my exposure but you guys have been
everywhere we have CGI we can use right
Dave Weigel loved seeing Dave Weigel on
there okay so let's get let's get some
updated results from the New York Times
and see where the numbers are right now
Michigan has been called for Joseph R
Biden Jr and that is the end of Bernie
Sanders campaign this is uh it's over so
that's it
we'll still be here and we're gonna see
what the other numbers are and sort of
where the different delegate numbers end
up but this this you know I I called it
a week ago and we have to play it all
out but this is essentially the end you
are still going to see people you are
going to see people say well you know if
everybody forgets to vote next week
other than Bernie supporters but this
this is the end and it that I mean what
else can we say
this is that's going to do it Joe Biden
has won Michigan and there is
essentially no more path for Bernie
Sanders to the nomination Wow Wow
it happened very very quickly but at the
same time if you're surprised by this
you basically haven't been paying
attention to the numbers so that is that
that is basically it now people
wondering why is this the case well
there's a few different things going on
first of all the the delegate lead has
now extended to 126 remember my
prediction and we're inching closer was
Biden plus 144 by the end of the night
it's now plus 126 Bernie is going to
lose delegates he's gonna fall further
behind next Tuesday so even if Bernie
managed to tie today it would
essentially be over but that is that is
basically it let's do some tweeting
let's see I actually helped me come up
with a tweet what's a clever tweet I can
send out related to what we just saw I
mean I it's time for me to announce the
the end okay actually somebody said the
stages of grief gab de I like that with
the Michigan win by Joe Biden it is
officially time
or Bernie supporters to move from the
denial phase of grief to the anger right
is that I think is dab de denial anger
dabbed bargaining depression and
acceptance is that right is this what
anybody want to modify this tweet I'm
willing to workshop it with people in
the chat anybody have any other ideas
skip the trying to okay to move on I
like that to move on from the denial
phase of grief fine I won't say anger
because I don't want to encourage anger
but that sounds pretty good I guess I
mean I guess that's it I don't know okay
well we did it if anybody wants to
retweet that IMD pakman IMD Pakman on uh
on Twitter okay so so anyway I believe
that that it certainly is it is over now
Han said let's see oh whoa we've got a
bunch of different super chats coming in
and let me see I don't want to miss
anything all I remember
if you'd oh wow I missed the bunt but
these really came in here easiest way to
giver to third parties okay Han says hi
David really appreciate your video a
while ago on the reality of Medicare for
all
it feels refreshing and outside of a
bubble thank you Alex since Iraq says if
Trudeau is an American and was the
Democratic Party elect to face off
against Trump who do you think would win
you know it's so hard to know it's very
very difficult to know wow thanks for
the retweets by the way I just saw 25
reef retweets pop up instantly on this
tweet that's that's wild
Adam Connelly says Flint Michigan I
voted for Bernie Skye bucks his all-time
favorite member of the Howard Stern Show
besides Howard you know I love elegant
Elliott often often he was great until
he went a little too crazy i I do like
beetlejuice I liked this guy
Tim who sadly passed away who would go
on and tell you everything you needed to
know about like what's the best type of
paper towel that's available it was
fascinating you can find the interview
on on YouTube Howard Stern Tiny Tim oh
and Eric the actor I see people saying
Eric the actor is absolutely absolutely
absolutely one one of my favorites and
sadly he has he has passed
Jonathan McCartney says any ideas as to
why Sanders was unable to capture the
african-american votes
I do have ideas but I'm gonna save them
for tomorrow's post mortem I'm gonna I'm
gonna save them a little bit okay we do
have a goal tonight of 89 new members on
my website join pakman.com we are
currently at 16 I'm inviting you to grab
a membership at join pakman.com you get
a whole bunch of free extra stuff we do
an entire show every day just for our
members and you're directly supporting
these streams including the very long
streams hundreds of hours of streams
that we've been doing around the 2020
primary and election state of the union
debates impeachment hearings all of that
stuff and my opinion is that the normal
membership prices are eminently
reasonable but I would encourage you if
you want to use that coupon code 2020
now available for only a limited time at
join pakman.com it'll save you 66% off
of the membership of your choice if you
are just joining us it is over
fortunately or unfortunately depending
on your perspective Joe Biden has easily
won Missouri Missouri Joe Biden may have
a historic win in Mississippi and
Michigan which was the one holdout for
Bernie Sanders has been called for
Joseph R Biden Jr and this eliminates
any path for Bernie Sanders to the
nomination Joe Biden now leads Bernie
Sanders in the popular vote by
essentially a full million votes 6
million to 5 million this is not going
to be a small victory by the time it is
all said and done the Michigan results
with 42% reporting have Joe Biden at
plus 12 in Michigan I did tweet and I
invite you to retweet me if you would
like with the Michigan wind by Joe Biden
it is officially time for Bernie
supporters to move on from the denial
phase of grief it is sad but it is the
reality and it is now a question of
would you rather Bernie over Trump or
despite disliking Trump would you rather
another four years of Trump and there
will be plenty of time plenty plenty
plenty of time to explore that my
instinct is that this ending sooner is
better than it being drawn out what can
I say now let's just look at the
comments I bet I'm getting crushed here
time to burn the party to the ground
this is why people get discouraged from
voting too many people still programmed
unfortunately thank you tell that to
your YouTube friends this tweet is from
someone I muted I love that
we tried unfortunately I agree this
sucks
Secretary of State said votes won't be
done until tomorrow it's been called
nope I'm still in denial Green Party not
voting dem ever miss Blair White oh wow
pretends to be shocked
I hate boomers we love you I was the
first like it's done Bernie will not
quit neither will we see this is the
stuff I don't get it's like okay you
don't have to quit but it's over I you
know I don't I don't totally understand
it time to bite the bullet and back
Biden more bust than Bernie am i right
Trump has one sad but true four more
years of Trump since you're a Bernie
supporter are you saying you were in
denial as well no I was not in denial
go check out my videos from a week ago
guess it was guaranteed to happen Bernie
and toolss it what on earth is this no
Bernie and tulsi supporters must support
third party candidates like Howie
Hawkins
okay well then Doug Trump will win if
you want Trump to win you can do that a
lot of third party time stuff like that
okay well so that that listen this this
is what's going on I can't change the
reality I can only report it to you as
it is
I am sorry I've been ignoring people on
twitch and I want to get back to that
right now and nononono I'm sorry quakes
7890 oh is the Washington Post now
calling Michigan we called it already
race in Michigan The Washington Post is
projecting that Joe Biden will win
Michigan Wolverine State Michigan has a
hundred and 25 delegates at stake
tonight that's the biggest haul of the
night let's head back now to the post
Jeremy Bowers with the election insights
team so Jeremy what's the map showing
you yes the map is very very important
here quakes 7890 has subscribed and says
I love Omni liberalism not a term I'm
familiar with anonymous gift er has
gifted a subscription to my channel from
two JLP talk which is Jesse Lee
Peterson's Channel I love it trihex has
raided welcomed trihex viewers very much
appreciate you joining me I don't know
who trihex
was supporting but I know that trihex is
an eminently reasonable person and I
apologize that I'm five minutes late
welcoming you all I was in the middle of
some kind of rant it is over for Bernie
Sanders Joe Biden has effectively won
and secured the Democratic primary
tonight and I want to welcome all of you
and appreciate all of you being here a
pre my dear Emmy says subscribed with
prime subscribed with prime and I very
much appreciate that as well okay let me
say thank you to Tim Hill Tim Hill is
new member number 17 tonight very much
appreciate your support Tim I also want
to say thanks to Michael kwinter Michael
kwinter is new member number 18 tonight
at join pakman.com we have listen it's a
very ambitious goal I understand it we
had 88 people sign up on Super Tuesday
my goal tonight is to beat that by one
that's why the goal is 89 so far 18
people have signed up I invite you to be
number 19
you can grab a membership at join
pakman.com discounts are available they
are not means tested it is just take it
if you want it the coupon code is 20 20
now okay
let me do a few Super chats I don't want
to fall behind on those if you are just
joining us on YouTube though make sure
to both like and subscribe to the
channel like the streams subscribe to
the channel okay
Michael Bradley says I've been a member
for about a month voted for Bernie in
Shiawassee County Michigan yeah let me
know via super chat who you voted for
and where you voted even if it was on
Super Tuesday or before ah P says ice
raided to poultry plants down the road
for me last week before you refused to
vote think about the families and
communities getting torn apart
Joseph van Scoy says what do you think
Bernie what do you think Biden will do
about climate change as president
haven't heard any candidate talk climate
policy in a long time carbon tax maybe I
am NOT very familiar with Biden's
climate policy I am sure it is not as
aggressive as the green New Deal but I
am sure it is far far better than Donald
Trump
Admiral beta's says interesting result
on box's map looks like Tulsi won Grand
Traverse County in Michigan unopposed at
ninety one point 67 reporting unopposed
why was no one else on the ballot there
is a question
Sol says who Nile Pune lay Jesus I have
no clue what that means
Scott Schoenberg says if Tulsi were the
nominee could she beat Trump probably
not Rasmus Hamaker sends a super chat
Denis Klump says tip from Netherlands
this election massively go for Biden
removed the fool from office show the
youth does vote and your opinion matters
force Democrats to take progressives
into his account extreme tuber says damn
David that casual savagery with the
unfit comet holy Scheib yes guy bows dog
says can Bernie convinced the black
voters to vote for him it's over Bernie
lost I am NOT gonna sugarcoat it it's
over Bryan Holaday says doesn't Bernie
doesn't Biden success
say a lot about Hillary's unpopularity
that is a very interesting side story
which I look forward to talking about
actually that is a very interesting
angle which I look forward to discussing
in the future let me say thank you and
welcome to Damien fan
Damien fan is new member number 19
tonight at join pakman.com let's see I
know that might my tweet is absolutely
going to Triggs verified people will
absolutely eviscerate me on Twitter and
it's funny I don't care because Twitter
is not real life let me see Blair White
responded a couple other blue checkmark
people as some people like to call them
have responded but so far it's really
mostly triggering just random people and
we have to deal with reality as it is
this is not about joking or anything
like that we have to deal with reality
as it is and unfortunately because of
these numbers we will have a sort of
center-left
democrat running against Donald Trump
once again we have numbers from three
states and Joe Biden has won all three
Mississippi with 14 percent reporting
Joe Biden is up 66 to 67 just a massive
victory riding on a 2/3 black electorate
the black electorate widely rejecting
Bernie Sanders in Missouri we have a
closer race with 8 percent reporting
Biden is plus 23 and then yes in
Michigan Joe Biden at plus 12 with 33
percent reporting and it indeed has been
called the updated totals for the
popular votes have Joe Biden just shy of
a million vote lead over Bernie Sanders
and that is that is where we are right
now
and we will see if that extends as the
evening goes on we are of course waiting
for North North Dakota where polls
closed already at 8:00 p.m. Eastern Time
but we have no data there Idaho the
polls closed at 10:00 p.m. and
Washington the
oles closed at 11:00 p.m. but it is
mostly academic at this point it is a
matter of how big will Jose delegate
lead get it is now 1:31 my very quick
glance tells me at 131 is the delegate
lead right now I predicted that Biden
would be at plus 144 by the end of the
evening it may exceed that I I may have
actually underestimated Joe Biden's lead
there let me say welcome to Eldad nine
who has subscribed with twitch prime I
also want to thank sac quintupled W for
the bits very much appreciated let me
also thank some new members because I
don't want to fall too far behind
Samuel night is new member number 20
tonight at join pakman.com and I really
appreciate your support Sam I also want
to say welcome to oh geun-tae know who
is new member number 21 tonight thank
you very much appreciate it consider if
you like the streams and you want to
support what we are doing consider
grabbing a membership at join pakman.com
Admiral beta's says oops never mind that
last message counting error okay Andrew
Tufts says thanks for the moszer my
grandfather veteran of WPA bridge
projects in Miami would always say Miami
always loved it Cheers hashtag feel the
burn
Bonnie W says voted Bernie in Missouri
we also had long student lines angel
Hernandez has Mac or PC if so why I'm
all on PC and Samsung I have no Apple
products whatsoever no regrets folks no
regrets stun ever says as usual the
biggest loser wins Lady of the lake says
go Bernie but few Biden plans align
plus-or-minus with progressives I'll
vote for transportation and better
Obamacare in his plan if he wins bug
reps to deliver he wins bug reps to
deliver yes ash house tad says I've lost
all hope and discussed this country we
are screwed incredible TVs TV says how
long will the David Pakman show
my hope is until you're 80 Wow can you
imagine that would be a long time
Brad O'Connor says if one finds Trump's
cognition concerning how does one vote
for Biden in good conscience I cannot
support the corporatist
status quo oops sorry for that scroll
guy LeFleur says maxed out my donation
for Sanders and don't regret it he is my
daddy and I love him
window zombie says good game USA I guess
you want Trump again
bay-buh doe says thank you David for
keeping it real Thoreau fir Beck says
good night and let's keep trying to make
1984 fiction again mr. app B says not
sure if I should stay home or vote Trump
hashtag spite hashtag spite John
McKinney says should Bernie drop out of
the race should Bernie supporters stop
voting for Bernie and give up no listen
if you support Bernie and there's an
election that hasn't yet happened go and
vote for Bernie it'll get them delegates
it'll give them more negotiating power
may be at the convention or if he drops
out or whatever now vote vote for who
you want to vote for for sure Andrew
says do you think that voting for a
third party such as Green Party is a
wasted vote no it's not wasted it'll
actually help Donald Trump win it won't
be wasted at all it will be very useful
very very useful to Donald Trump if
you're just joining us oh is this live
as this Bernie live
I voted against the war in Iraq Joe Joe
Biden voted for The Wall Street bailouts
I helped lead the effort against the
Wall Street bailout this is a deflated
Bernie guys Joe voted for disastrous
trade agreements which have been
horrific for the Midwest now my point
here my point here is not to criticize
Biden my point here is to ask you to
think that in a general election which
candidate can generate the enthusiasm
and the excitement and the voter turnout
we need now Sanders went into this race
extremely focused on voter turnout the
idea yes all right so the voter turnout
discussion happening there
this seems must be earlier White House
video since it is nighttime here on the
East Coast now so not sure what they're
doing over on PBS but let's get an
updated look at the delegate count Joe
Biden has now surged to a 139 delegate
lead over Bernie Sanders I predicted 144
I'm gonna be wrong in that I didn't
expect I I underestimated the delegate
lead for Biden by the time this is all
said and done okay
updated numbers from the New York Times
with 21% reporting Biden remains plus 66
67 in Mississippi in Missouri with 11
percent reporting Biden is plus 24 and
then with Michigan at 36% it has been
called Joseph R Biden Jr is plus 12 and
a half almost exactly I believe so so
far a very very good night for Joe Biden
if you are just joining us I have called
not just any individual races I've
called the primary for Joe Biden he
like it I understand but I'm telling you
guys the the truth if you're just
joining the stream also please make sure
on youtube to like and subscribe like
and subscribe it really helps us if
you're joining me on Twitch make sure to
follow my twitch channel we're just 20
followers from 29000 which is a
beautiful beautiful round number and of
course I want to thank people who
continue to sign up on my website
Dillon Linville is new member number 22
at join pakman.com Ford Brasher is new
member number 23 at join pakman.com
let's do a giveaway I know a lot of
people are feeling down let's give away
some stuff new member number 25 tonight
at join pakman.com I'll send you the
item of your choice from my online store
david pakman.com slash gear you can pick
a t-shirt you can pick a coffee mug we
have black coffee mugs white coffee mugs
all sorts of cool stuff new member
number 25 and this can happen very very
quickly
we often get like 5 people will sign up
at once new member number 25
chronologically I will personally get
you a free item from my website and I
will enjoy doing it even even more so ok
JC says Zed Jelani has been writing
Twitter threads about why Bernie failed
so hard in the final months I haven't
seen him but I'm interested Beezus see
Christ says before you talk about why
the black voter did what they did
tonight please talk to your friend
Benjamin Dixon first he will give you
accurate insight ok yeah I would let's
actually let's send a tweet about that
[Music]
before discussing why the black vote
went over whelmingly for Biden I would
love to hear Benjamin
Dickson's take on it as he has been
following this closely good
all right let's tweet that continuing
with the tweets on Twitter
to quote Bernie Sanders okay good other
super chats that are coming in yo soy
baboso says Tulsi garbage is running
because she loves the new lifestyle
everything is paid for her clothes meals
and traveling Buch Tulsi fook Biden very
aggressive
Justin DPS says if Biden gets into the
public eye enough and is considered non
met not mentally fit by the DNC could
Bernie takes Biden's place as nominee
wishful thinking listen I already said
if Donald Trump has remained president
for three years despite pretty clear
cognitive decline as outlined on my
program by everything from psychiatrists
to all sorts of other professionals III
don't think it's actually going to
restrict Joe Biden incredibly enough me
an Arendt renders says seven Republicans
in the Supreme Court now what do you
think it's going that direction unless
we get from Bell MacLaine racing I would
rather have four more years of Trump
than a potential eight years of the
establishment I I disagree with you on
the issue of judges because these judges
are going to remain for decades decades
decades and it is going to have such a
disastrous impact long after Trump is
gone voting for corporations in major
cases and against the individual it's
gonna be very very ugly so I think I
don't agree with you for that reason and
others Dean Dinobot to says there are
still roughly a hundred total delegates
from Super Tuesday to be distributed
Colorado and Utah still each have more
than 20% of their votes to count those
delegates probably won't matter in the
end but does it normally take this long
I don't believe it normally takes this
long I don't believe it does Quags says
we're the hundred and two burn delegate
left from last Tuesday I okay I mean it
you can you can wait on that but I have
called it
devyn tooth Minh says can we officially
call the general election dementia bol I
am going to address that later today or
I'm sorry later this week not not today
John McKinney says should Bernie Sanders
drop out probably not I mean it's over
but Bernie is going to be able to get
many more delegates so he probably I
mean if he wants to avoid an
embarrassing loss in Florida he should
drop out if he wants to get more
delegates he should just stay in William
Henning says I live in Wisconsin our
primary is in April is it still worth it
to vote for Bernie even though it's late
in the game yes vote for the person you
support if they are still in the race
they will get delegates it is a sign of
support absolutely you should do it
Justin Ward says okay wait wait wait but
if we add all of Warren and gabbard's
votes to Bernie's oh no well time for me
to transfer gracefully into the anger
stage mr. app B says David like with
Hillary and her investigation is there
no possibility the Biden investigation
will make him a liability absolutely
there is absolutely a possibility of
that Randy H says if Bernie can leverage
his endorsement of Biden in exchange for
getting one or a couple progressive
positions in his cabinet which should
they be well health and human services
which by the way is on the screen right
now Health and Human Human Services I
would be looking at we can think more
about that as the this process continues
Sam Anderson says I voted for Bernie in
Minnesota if Biden somehow wins the
general what is the likelihood a
progressive stands a chance in the near
future the progressive movement would be
hurt if Biden wins against Trump there
are conflicting priorities here the best
thing for the progressive movement is
for Biden to lose the Trump that's very
bad for the country because Trump gets
four more years of not dealing with
climate Trump gets four more years of
elective selecting judges likely at
least one more Supreme Court justice it
will be one of the most lopsided Supreme
Court's we will have had in a very very
long time so there there are actually
some conflicting conflicting priorities
here and that is going to make
is going to go on between now and
November a mess let me say thank you and
welcome oh let's see here because we
have a we have an offer on the table on
the table here new member number 24 is
David Dean our new member number 25 is
Carmen Ritter Carmen you get the free
item from the David Pakman show store
david pakman.com slash gear use the
contact form on my website to let me
know the item you want size and color if
it's a shirt just color if it's a coffee
mug as well as your shipping address and
we will get that to you and I also want
to welcome Nicolas cook who is new
member number 26 tonight and Gianni guru
bow who is new member number 27 tonight
the goal is 89 at join pakman.com and I
invite all of you to grab a membership
there let's see what they are talking
about here with the Washington Post we
can look at Mississippi Missouri and
Michigan and see where where Biden has
done pretty well and we already heard
from Jeremy and Lenny who said that he's
done really well among black voters and
that's undoubtedly true but it's also
done really well among older voters and
those voters 65 and older
made up a larger share of the electorate
than those 30 and under couple of dates
and Biden did really well among those
older voters almost 9 and 10 voters in
Mississippi 65 and older voted for Biden
about 8 and 10 in Missouri and about 3
quarters in Michigan so those are big
shares of this older electorate that
turned out young and voted you can't win
if you lose the old we also found that
Biden had a lot of support from people
who describe themselves as Democrats
which is not surprising and Sanders has
tended to do better
among candidate who call themselves
independents who can also vote in many
Democratic primaries and show up and
answered the exit poll question and when
they ask them what their party is they
say oh I'm an independent and but among
Democrats and Biden won by a
double-digit margins in Michigan Sanders
led by Biden by just over 10 points
among the 3 and 10 who call themselves
independents
but that's way worse than his margin was
four years ago against Hillary Clinton
that's interesting is this information
is being asked of people as they is so
it seems as though at least in Michigan
Bernie did worse among independents than
he did last last time and that is gonna
make it very very tough very very tough
to win let's look at the latest numbers
in Mississippi with 29 percent reporting
Biden is +61 plus 61 brutal in Missouri
with 20 percent reporting Biden is plus
25 a big big win much bigger than the
polls suggested and in Michigan with 40
percent reporting a Biden is plus 12
point 7 12 point 7 the margin right now
in Michigan these are really big wins
and this has pushed the margin to 148 am
i right there 148 doing some quick math
the margin of delegate lead for Joe
Biden is now 148 delegates which is
bigger than I predicted I predicted it
would be 144 I underestimated it
significantly let me say thank you to
ney Hodge who is a twitch prime
subscriber on twitch new twitch prime
subscriber I want to say welcome to say
he who has subscribed for 7 months with
prime with the message I like Biden Geo
poison has subscribed at Tier one thank
you very much very much appreciate all
of your support and appreciate everybody
who's been on the streams on YouTube
twitch as well as Facebook we are also
live on Facebook with a humbler sized
audience let me let me put it that way
okay Tyler Kuhn says there's talk at
UMass my alma mater that's me speaking
at my alma mater the undergraduate about
shutting down for the semester due to
the virus other colleges have been doing
so thoughts on schools closing I'm the
wrong person to ask you got to ask the
medical experts I don't I don't know
Jane womanpower says we all love David
Lyfe like and subscribe thank you for
the reminder Jane if you are watching on
YouTube please like and subscribe we
should be able to get to 2,000 likes
pretty easily just a reminder like and
subscribe it's free the like hammer
and the SUBSCRIBE hammer absolutely use
them they are free Alice B says any
plausible way Bernie can come back know
why or why not in layman's terms
well because bernie is losing by more
with every passing minute and he is
going to lose next Tuesday
voted Bernie and Utah ready to vote
Biden in the general election thanks
David John McKinney says Justin Amash is
considering a third-party run that would
take votes from Trump how likely do you
think it is I have no idea how likely it
is I hope he does it because it would be
bad for Trump Miguel Palacio says is it
possible for Biden to win a plurality
yeah well yes Biden Biden is winning a
plurality right I mean he has a
plurality of the delegates the question
is can he win a majority which is 1991 I
don't know if you may be meant to ask
that but yes he can
Rasmus haymaker says conspiracy folks
somehow conflate your argentinian
background with ratlines
consolidates this by pointing out that
microphone stand reads heil why so this
is a very well known microphone stand
brand it's just some guy I think his
name is like Marv Kyle or something like
that it has nothing to do with Hitler
and my family is Jewish so we were not
smuggling Nazis into Argentina but I
cannot recommend highly enough
I am currently reading Neil Bascomb's
book about the capture of Nazi kill Nazi
not Nazi killer Jew killer Adolf
Eichmann his capture in Argentina under
the name he was living under the name
Ricardo Klement
and Neel Bascomb's book about this is
absolutely fantastic it's a few years
old but I plan to uh when I finished the
book I plan to reach out to Neil and
just tell them congratulations it is an
incredible incredible book and you you
should absolutely absolutely check it
out okay Zach Bushman says Biden has a
stutter circumlocution explains most of
his speech defects all his dementia
unfitness talk is pretty offensive so
listen I believe Biden has clearly
slowed down now that he's nearly 80 or
compared to 2012 when he debated Paul
Ryan I think a lot of what we were
seeing you were absolutely right about
no no question
Jordan Alex says one thing I think that
Sanders supporters overlooked in this
primary is that Biden is nowhere near as
obscenely unlikable as Hillary Clinton
that is true that is very true
Baron Steuben says what needs to change
about the progressive movement in order
to start winning you we need better
candidates Bernie has the right policies
on a lot of stuff but you know this
isn't new I'm not now Monday morning
quarterbacking I've been saying this for
since 2016 why is he calling himself a
Democratic Socialist you're not gonna
win with missourah democrats in northern
florida democrats if that's what you
call yourself why does he have toxic
people around him like this Imam from
two nights ago who once said Isis seems
to be in cahoots with Israel I mean it's
it's you know why is someone like that
even tangentially involved Linda Sarsour
etc you know it's it there we just need
better candidates with the right
policies no question about it John
McKinney sorry for the grammar my phone
was acting like an idiot here's the
proper grammar
I heard Justin Amash is considering a
third party run is this a good idea it's
a good idea for us it's a bad idea for
Donald Trump
Keaton clapper has hey hey David hope
you're having a great day your hair is
yeah it's a pretty good hair day you get
hurt Azim Abu Khalil says as a Bernie
supporter it's heartbreaking to see
Biden of all people become the
Democratic presidential nominee that
being said the Bernie or bust people are
delusional if they'd rather have four
more years of Trump than eight years of
Biden Justin Ward says seeing how young
voters overwhelmingly support Sanders
can we expect the population to become
more progressive in the coming decades
or do voters tend to become more
moderate conservative as they get older
no the people stay roughly equal in
their politics as they age but
subsequently younger generations are
more and more progressive again I think
it's important to understand that even
if the country becomes more progressive
you still need good candidates and that
is not that is certainly not going to
change let's get some updated numbers
Mississippi we have Biden plus 61 which
is Barrett basically where he's been all
night in Missouri we have Biden plus 25
also where he's been most of the night
and in Michigan we have Biden plus 13
the numbers have remained very very even
as they've come in the delegate math is
still 148 for Joe Biden 148 is now the
lead my prediction was 144 so we are
close but we still have North Dakota
that may end up being a tie Idaho which
may end up being a tie and then whether
I end up being right or wrong not that
it matters it's just a curiosity it'll
really come down to Washington the
delegate numbers because North Dakota
and Idaho have such small delegate
numbers and it may be close the the math
is ultimately maybe going to be decided
by Washington closing at 11:00 p.m.
Eastern Time about an hour and 20
minutes from now let's see what we have
happening on PBS interesting that he is
I want to talk about the decisions that
John was making on the trail he made
several voyages out into the West as you
say not all of this was undiscovered
territory okay but Harold this seems
completely unrelated to what we are
focusing on tonight which are the
election results as interesting as I'm
sure what what they're talking about is
let me say welcome to a few new people
Alice batter Minh is new member number
28 tonight Alice thank you so much I so
appreciate your support I also want to
say thanks to my good buddy
Colin Francois who is new member number
29 tonight we are taking signups at join
pakman.com the coupon code 2020 now
saves you 66% and we have a it's an
admittedly ambitious goal of 89
subscribers okay I'm being told that
Andrew yang has just endorsed Joe Biden
let's see what he says the movement can
okay so no that's old
let's see here where is that endorsement
does anybody know these are mostly all
retweets and for you okay so I guess I
don't know I don't know where that is if
anybody can tell me where we can see by
the way why aren't they letting yang
speak in this debate he did it on CNN oh
okay
in that case let's search for Andrew
yang endorse and search for videos and
see if we can find it on your paper a
lot we haven't heard from you a little
bit
you haven't where do you see the race
right now what do you see it's going for
Joe Biden
I believe that Joe Biden will be the
Democratic nominee and I've always said
I'm going to support whoever the nominee
is so I hereby am endorsing Joe Biden to
be not just the nominee for the Donner
Party but the next president of the
United States
Wow when I say this having supported
Bernie Sanders in 2016 Bernie was an
inspiration for me inspired my run but
the math says Joe is our prohibitive
nominee we need to bring the party
together we need to start working on
defeating Donald Trump in the fall
I've had many personal conversations
with Joe about the impact of the fourth
Industrial Revolution on the middle
class I believe that he's the right man
for the job to help us not just a feed
Donald Trump but govern the country in
the years ahead and the question is I
guess I have for you this what does he
need to do to bring the yang gang and
the Sanders folks Wow and what do you
say to your supporters who who might
support Sanders
so let's retweet this let's see which
version I want to do I don't know either
of these two people I guess I will oh
whoa a whole bunch of stuff coming in
let me find the that was weird noise
things are just scrolling very very
quickly where was that old video at that
first video I found that's the one I
want to retweet this is very weird where
did that video go it's like it just
disappeared did anybody see that sits
down for an interview very strange I
guess I'll retweet this one no this
video is trash okay well I guess I'm not
retweeting it I don't know where those
good videos just disappeared
maybe they were copyright
lamed or something by CNN who on earth
knows okay grace Lee says so states that
vote June 2nd our votes effectively
don't matter now right since Biden's
lead is too big unfortunately that's
true
I mean Biden won by Biden Biden's
winning Biden will be the nominee but
you should still vote I don't want to
discourage anybody from voting
[Music]
omniscience says is it possible for
Obama to become VP for Biden and how
would you feel if such a move was pulled
I believe it would be a great move I
believe it is possible I recently
tweeted about this there is some debate
over whether Biden could be Joe could
have Obama as his vice president now the
rule says in order to be vice president
you must be constitutionally eligible to
be president some people interpret that
to mean because Obama served two terms
he's not constitutionally eligible to be
President
that's not my read that constitutionally
eligible means you're old enough and
you're natural born and as a result I
believe that yes Obama could be Biden's
VP I don't think he would ever do it and
if Biden were to die
Obama would be able to serve the
remainder of Biden's term as president I
believe that is the law okay but I don't
I don't think it would I don't think
would happen although I think it would
be a really good idea grungey dan has
cheered J Square says on Twitch with a
subscription keep up the great work
David you never cease to offer a voice
of reason in these turbulent times
progressives don't give up fighting for
what's right yes very very very much so
some people like the idea of a of a
Biden Obama ticket in fact let's tweet
about that let's put together a tweet my
understanding is that Barack Obama could
be Joe Biden's vice president and could
even serve the remainder the the
remainder of a Biden term and could even
serve the remainder of a Biden term if
necessary
is there any better pick striated a
something about is there anyone Biden
could pick that would make it more
likely that he wins I I don't know that
there is how do I want a word this maybe
I can get some ideas
Warren yeah I'm not sure about that
I'll just put thoughts yeah there we go
okay all right we're continuing to watch
the results come in and in fact let's
get let's get an update on the results
now Mississippi Biden has won big
Missouri Wyden has won a little bit less
big Michigan Biden has won so far a
little bit less big we are waiting on
numbers from North Dakota polls have
closed at 8:00 p.m. it is what is called
a I believe that's called a firehouse
caucus isn't it then we have Idaho and
or is Idaho the fire house caucus now I
don't remember and then we have
Washington those are the ones that that
that we are waiting on at this point in
time let's see what people think about
my idea of a of a Biden Obama ticket
let's take a look here that would be the
best me member ever 22nd amendment says
no stop unconstitutional David is it a
joke dumpster fire Putin 2.0 wait
seriously no not good no could be you
know not do that stupid as f oh no Biden
will not be the presidency okay yeah
very good
all right now I do want to do the Andrew
yang endorse yeah Andrew yang endorse I
want to retweet this video if possible
okay here it is Andrew yeah
has endorsed Joe Biden after Biden
already won the primary tonight not
hugely or no let's see anybody surprised
I am I am not at all surprised
Andrew yang said he would support the
winner and Biden is the is the winner
tonight okay oh did I tweet something
that was misspelled that would be hugely
embarrassing let me see if I did that
wouldn't be good
Andrew yang has endorsed his oh geez
hold on let me delete that we want to
well everything going wrong here
everything going wrong all right here we
go let's actually do it properly
Andrew yang has endorsed by Dhin after
Biden already won the primary tonight
anybody's surprised there we go okay
results continue to come in I do want to
read some more super chats though
because those also continue to come in
Beezus see how rice says I have a
stutter that is not a stutter Miguel
upon a CEO says so if Bryden does not
win a majority is it possible for
Sanders or another candidate to take it
instead it's possible it's not gonna
happen
Joseph Dizzy's says I hope you're having
a great poram David good night
yes hog Sameach F RBE says who do you
think will be Biden's VP can't be Liz
because of Senate seat think it will be
Clovis our hope it is not cotton wala
yeah I think that the the most likely
people would be Kamala or Amy in looking
at everything that I've seen so far okay
other super chance lots of jello says
what do you say to Bernie or Buster's
who are willing to have four more years
of Trump just to teach the DNC a lesson
I disagree with them Jorge Luis 88 says
can the DNC cancel somehow the general
election debates to keep up with the
strategy of hiding hiding Joe Biden they
certainly could again
I don't think it's going to matter teach
me guitar says
the nomination is most important yes but
earning delegates is also very important
to force our movement into the DNC
platform the primary process is our
version of a parliament so keep fighting
yeah I believe that
if you planned to vote for Bernie you
should vote for Bernie whether it's in
Florida or wherever he will get
delegates it makes his movement stronger
so on and so forth
John McKinney says should Biden pick
Verte Bernie as his VP should I don't
know will absolutely not Doug E this
election is basically the establishment
telling the people they don't matter in
the long run listen I don't know that
that's the right narrative for the left
because when you look at the popular
vote Joe Biden now has a 1.1 million
vote lead over Bernie Sanders that can't
just be blamed on the establishment and
the DNC
1.1 million more people said given the
options I'm going to vote for Biden over
Bernie 1.1 million I don't know that we
do ourselves any favors in the
progressive movement if we just say the
establishment took it from Bernie
when Bernie's down 1.1 million votes in
a primary okay that that is a big that
is a big big difference let me say thank
you to Jack jetty at Jedi who says on
Twitch with the subscription enjoy the
content keep up the fight for sanity
grungy dan has sent the CHEO I already
think the grungy Dan okay not going to
do that again very very good if you're
just joining us on YouTube if you were
hoping for a Bernie win I don't have
good news Bernie Sanders is I am calling
it done it has not been called in any
official sense and of course the
delegate math is still far from 1991
delegates but Joe Biden has won at all
three states so far and is now leading
by 154 delegates even more than I
predicted and I believe that Bernie
Sanders has no mathematical path that is
reasonable to the nomination at this
point in time the numbers are
overwhelming in Mississippi Bernie with
a 61 point margin
they are pretty overwhelming in Missouri
with a 24-point margin and Biden with a
currently 34 thirteen and a half point
margin in Michigan all three states have
been called for Joseph R Biden Jr and
with Florida and more than 200 delegates
looming next Tuesday I believe it is
over and that that I would I will not
shield you from the truth my friends
Gregory shavers jr. says Biden has no
appeal for me to vote for him you're not
alone in feeling that one eight two two
one three eight says that's a dangerous
president President Obama as vice
president some people don't like it
Ryan Olding says how do you think Stacey
Abrams would go as Biden's VP I this has
been mentioned to me I don't believe
there is any chance that Stacey Abrams
will be vide ins Biden's VP John
McKinney says just to be clear I don't
want a recession but it is a recession
the only way Biden can beat Trump it
would be it would seriously help them I
don't want a recession either but
generally speaking it's very difficult
to take out an incumbent president when
the economy is perceived to be doing
well and it is it is very much about the
economy so youyou are certainly on to
something kwb says do we really want to
fight about whether Obama is eligible
for VP would be a massive waste of time
and energy and a corruption talking
point for the Republicans yeah I don't
know that I'm seriously proposing it but
it is a compelling idea to me
a photo says do you think Biden's poor
speech and forgetfulness is really a
problem especially if he's up against
the guy in the White House yeah like I
said you know it is it is very dishonest
and cynical for Trump supporters who
have ignored Trump's obvious cognitive
issues - now say Biden has dementia well
so you're gonna vote for Trump does that
does that make sense
Diana Brigid says thanks for giving the
news without angry rhetoric Thank You
Jane woman power says smart viewers like
and subscribe late in Canada nighty yes
if you're joining us on YouTube
make sure to hit that like and subscribe
button it is very important to our
YouTube channel that be done Alex since
Iraq says was Jesse Lee Peterson
friendly to you in person yes he was he
was very friendly max says I don't have
it in me to canvas for joe FR b e says
would bernie dropping out ASAP help
biden sure I mean then Biden gets like
all the remaining delegates the question
is does it help him in November and I
don't know the answer to that Viper X
says what do you think of Bloomberg
being vide ins VP I think it's a bad
idea I would not do that if I was Joe
Biden I would very much stay away from
that idea I don't think that it's a good
idea let's see if we have anything new
from the Washington Post CERN's
regarding the corona virus caused the
senator to cancel his planned Ohio rally
tonight and we're still waiting for live
remarks from Joe Biden's azuma this all
right you may hear from Joe Biden at
some point soon that would be very very
interesting Washington may be soon to
start coming in we we don't exactly know
yet but we are indeed waiting for
remarks from Joseph R Biden Jr which I
am curious he was shot out of a cannon
last week when he had the good results
we'll see what we get from him tonight
and then we will see we may actually be
moments from results in more states now
at the top of the hour we're gonna keep
a very close eye on that nothing yet
from North Dakota polls have been closed
for a while Idaho polls closed now or
two minutes from now so we will see what
we get there but it is mostly academic
at this point in time okay let's see if
you have any question for me and
remember if you voted at all in this
primary let me know via YouTube super
chat where you voted and for whom you
voted I want to hear that C gonzo lewd
says someone put Kyle kolinsky on
suicide watch
okay I don't know exactly what that's
about but I'm guessing yeah he probably
is not super thrilled about what's going
on would be my guess and the progressive
movement certainly cannot be thrilled
Biden there's no question about that but
alas he is going to be the nominee
terminal says Biden won't install
conservative judges and might reinstate
some environmental protections suck it
up guys I love Bernie too but suck it up
vote blue Biden will do the things you
said Justin Ward says if your main
concern is campaign finance reform does
it make sense to vote for Biden into
general the odds of Bernie having gotten
through the campaign finance reform you
likely want are almost zero so if
campaign finance reform is your primary
issue then you should pick a secondary
issue and evaluate Biden versus Trump on
that okay huh there's a poll on twitch
and I don't know who made it I didn't
make it and it says who will you vote
for in the general that's interesting I
don't even know how that is that's who
did that maybe one of my mods I'm not
really sure but overwhelmingly the
numbers are going to Joe Biden there let
me remind you that we do have a target
tonight of 89 new members on my website
join pakman.com those website
memberships are the best way to support
the streams the show the YouTube channel
the twitch streams all of that stuff
grab a membership at join pakman.com I
will thank you live on stream sing your
praises live on stream and I will be
also we will also watch the blue bar
fill up currently at 29 looking for 89
and it's ambitious but I believe that we
can do it any moment now we are
expecting results to start coming in
from additional states let's see nothing
still nothing yet still nothing yet but
presumably very very soon we are also
waiting for a statement from Joe Biden
on what is for him a very very good
night let's see here brian lloyd says
i'm a warren voter and not enthusiastic
with Biden but in the end being
disaffected and not supporting Biden
means another Trump term hashtag blue no
matter who casual Thursday says hey
David some whiny punk
attacked me on your subreddit I will
unsubscribe now good luck to you and
your hype trains okay I mean okay I hope
it was worth five dollars to tell me
that
Liam sheriff's says even though Burnie
lost he started a movement that that
very well may be true that very well may
be true and he did lose that that is the
unfortunate reality
Chad Williams says is Pete Joe's best
option seems like Pete wants to be Obama
and is more appealing to a good portion
of Millennials you know my instinct is
that Biden is going to pick a woman for
his VP running mate that that's my sense
and I could be wrong but that's sort of
the the way that I believe it is going
to go let me say thank you to Nara who
has subscribed with twitch prime over on
Twitch also really appreciate my new
twitch followers who have gotten us to
29,000 followers on Twitch dodging rain
says policy over party what are your
thoughts about this I generally agree
with that Colin Stephens says voting for
Biden feels like a Republican I'm
staying home then you help Trump John
McKinney says Hillary Clinton won Super
Tuesday in twice in 2008 and Barack
Obama in 2008 I don't even know what
that means Hillary Clinton supporters
day I don't know what you're talking
about John Robert Braun says can't tell
if I'm more excited or sad at the
prospect of a trump Biden debate it's
going to be a dumpster fire yes it is
wasp says I'm a Swede observing this
election from afar and although I would
have loved to see Bernie as the
candidate I wouldn't hesitate to vote
Biden very mature of you James Bell says
David can I carry your children maybe I
don't know enough about biology to
answer that question my friend we are
continuing to wait on results that
really should be coming in any second
now
still nothing nothing out of North
Dakota nothing out of Idaho let me see
if we have any numbers elsewhere we will
take a look at
Vox and see what we've got they have
also nothing from North Dakota nothing
from Idaho and of course we wouldn't
expect anything yet from Washington the
delegate count remains at Biden plus 154
Biden is at plus 150 for the popular
vote numbers are approaching a 1.15
million vote lead for Joseph R Biden Jr
as we await results let's see what they
have to say about Idaho the City of
Boise is and when those votes come in at
Idaho we're going to see a lot of votes
from the northern parts of the state and
the eastern parts of the state but these
are going to be very small counties some
of them have only a single voting
precinct and may have somewhere between
50 and 200 votes in them what we're
really watching is the votes that come
in there in Ada County of Boise City you
know the other things we're watching is
the state of Washington the state of
Washington has a mail-in campaign
ballots which means voters were able to
make their decisions early on and send
their ballots in over a long period of
time right now this could actually
benefit the Sanders campaign here in the
state it's fully possible that many of
the votes were cast earlier than Joe
Biden's resurgence on Super Tuesday and
so it's possible that Sanders is gonna
punch above his weight here in the state
but those are the kinds of things we'll
be watching for later tonight Libya
thanks so much
I'd like to welcome my guest this our
national political reporter James Holman
I'll see you Jean Scott Dave why
Galesburg thanks for being here and
welcome back David Weigel national
political re gonna be here if a whole
bunch of you do it he has a tablet right
there
okay tweet to Dave Weigel and you can
tag me in on it
Dave we love you and we're watching you
on the David Pakman stream he's a fan of
the David Pakman show you saw him reach
right there he's probably starting to
get dings on that tablet I'm sure he has
his Twitter up let's start a campaign to
tweet what I mean you know we're just
waiting on results let's tweet to Dave
Weigel that you're watching him on the
David Pakman stream and that we love him
we love Dave Weigel who's been traveling
all around we're hoping he doesn't get
the the cool virus Dave Weigel on
Twitter da ve w e IG e
I believe let's see here
Dave Weigel my spelling is atrocious
here yeah here he is Dave waggle and as
you can see he follows me
he has his half a million followers and
we absolutely love it we love it all and
we want to make sure Dave waggle is
appreciated there okay other super chats
continue to come in Beezus asks or says
the reddit comment was a concern troll
similar to the narrative that corporate
media pushes out about Biden bros about
Bernie bros someone was mean so he
unsubscribed Miguel Palacios says hey
David should people still canvass for
Sanders I can't tell people what to do
people should do what it what is best
for them casual Thursday says yes it was
worth it unsubscribe imminent I am God
okay
oh this may be about Bernie headed back
to Vermont answering some questions from
reporters he didn't sound all that
confident about Michigan and I think we
can see why reflected in the returns at
least the preliminary returns tonight
but he was supposed to hold a rally in
Cleveland Ohio and that's where he was
going to sort of you know deliver a
speech or make some remarks about the
evening but his plan to do that we're
pretty abruptly scrapped late in the
afternoon his campaign said look you
know given the concerns about the spread
of the corona virus we are not going to
hold that rally and so they had to
cancel that at the last minute and here
we are in Burlington right now which of
course is senator Sanders in stone town
but it's not clear at this hour what if
anything he's going to say tonight
whether he's going to make me wait until
we see some of these western states
report some of the returns because he
states like Washington and Idaho might
be more favorable to him it's clearly
been a very very difficult and tough
night making the returns we've seen so
far so we're working the Senate campaign
about what if anything he's gonna be
paying or doing tonight can you give us
some insights on into the calculations
they have to make like what Bernie
Sanders and his team have to think
through as they decide if he should
address
supporters tonight if you should make a
statement and what he should say if he
does decide to do that well if you're
going to make a statement about an
election night about a primary night
then you want to have something
generally positive to say to your
supporters and so right now I think what
they're looking at is where Bernie
enticing that is there gonna be a state
that we can say we want is there
something we can tell our supporters hey
here's a place where we succeeded it
what we set out to do if there's a
reason why you know we can and should
keep going and it's up right now that's
our when you look at the map when you
look at Michigan when you look at
Missouri you look at Mississippi there's
yeah that we know so the map part the
interesting part is Bernie Bernie being
back in in Vermont at this point in time
let's see other super Chad's Jackson
says corn popped 20/20 for Jimmy the
lines his nomination taken from Biden
after Bernie is out unlikely marks grad
gaming says assuming Biden wins the
candidacy how do you predict this would
affect the 2024 election assuming Trump
jr. is running like he said he will I've
not seen from jr. say that I don't know
so look Dave Weigel he's got to be
looking down and seeing these coming in
right now if you guys are actually
tweeting him the way I've been
suggesting Dave waggle looked sucked in
right there to his to his to his tablet
has any how many people did actually
send Dave Weigel a tweet one two I guess
only two oh three four all right he's
probably noticing some of these tweets
would be my guess very very but we're
having a great time grand old time here
okay
pyro plasma says Trump is going to win
arm up now protect yourself Joseph van
Scoy says maybe it's time for Bernie to
press the progressive torch to someone
younger calling yourself a socialist is
not helpful maybe this is a rejection of
Bernie and not a rejection of
progressivism agree 100% this is not a
rejection of the policies this is a
rejection of Bernie John McKinney
Hillary beat Obama the March primaries
in 2008 and more endorsements and Obama
still became the
the may may happen to Bernie I'm not not
even expecting that but something to
consider okay
I don't know that that's true but we'll
look it up Grandma's Boy says couldn't
bernie dominate the debate and come back
I don't I don't think so
Mohamed Pope says I don't know the point
of participating anymore I understand
Jackson says when Trump and Biden have
to drop out due to cool virus you know
who will be left that's right David bill
weld versus Tulsi Gabbard Tulsi 2020 and
sarcasm
Ryan Henry Dean says what about sherrod
Brown is VP to shore up the Midwest
isn't it shore up in any case I like I
like sherrod Brown strategically but I
think they're going to pick a woman
vintage Barbie says vote blue we need to
stick together
casual Thursday says hey David did you
like Blade Runner 2049 I did but not as
much as the original Blade Runner
Jason Pope says will Biden support DC
and Puerto Rico statehood I think he
would likely support it but he wouldn't
make it his issue let's see if Dave
shouts us out left was sympathetic to
him that if he got to a general election
he would increase turnout he's been
saying he's been modulating some of his
rhetoric and saying that he will
increased youth turnout in a general
election implication being he's not
really done in a big way this time but
the story in a lot of these states is
that suburban voters who sat on the
sidelines in 2016 maybe to get into
their heads a little bit in 2016 at this
point in the four years ago we all
looked and felt a lot more energetic at
least me that that Hillary Clinton's
gonna be the nominee Donald Trump if he
was the nominee Democrats thought he
couldn't win so there was just a lot of
playing with the houses money for
Democratic voters and say and a lot of
protest voting for Sanders not just
protests voting on I hate all these
people's voting along lines of I like
his ideas I want to move in this
direction he won't win anyway so what's
the harm and I don't I think that spirit
is gone because of how agonizing 2016
was for Democrats there's a great desire
to end this
even though looking at the exit polling
in all these states so far certainly
when Washington comes in voters agreed
with Sanders on Medicare for all on his
key on his key issues he never did close
the gap with voters who thought I liked
him I'm not sure if he can get elected
and get this done why does that Harley
not a problem but an argument that sunk
in because people just did not see him
if you look at look at again the polling
on not character where she does very
well not honesty what she does very well
but on uniting the country and
delivering on the agenda he does much
better than Joe up so he does much worse
than Joe Biden let's check in with Joyce
ko who's been covering in the same Davis
absolutely spot-on and we've seen the
minister who sees your messages okay
let's see here I do want to welcome in
viña gotta Polly who is new member
number thirty tonight we have breached
thirty we do have a huge he or I would
ash actually a huge discount code the
coupon code is twenty twenty now at join
pakman.com the way it works is you sign
up you get tons of awesome stuff you
support independent media I say your
name and then the blue not line the blue
bar continues to fill up that's the way
it works let's see if we have any
updated numbers at all we do not let's
see Michigan numbers continue to come in
Biden has won Michigan Biden has won
Missouri and Biden has one Mississippi
we are waiting on North Dakota Idaho and
Washington and we are waiting on Joe
Biden who was scheduled to start
speaking at 9:30 and they have still not
seen him they have still not seen him
let's do a shout-out tweet now to dave
Weigel dipping in and out of dave Weigel
commentary on washington post live
stream why goal is on point as usual
this was not a rejection of Bernie's
policies but a reflection of the DEM
electorates view of Bernie as an
individual as a person what am I trying
to say it's not really as a person it's
more of as as the role he would play you
knighting or whatever as a politician as
a candidate it's personality but a
reflection of the electorate view of
Bernie Bernie himself yeah I like that
that's the best dipping in and out of de
vigo commentary on Washington Post live
stream why goes on point as usual yeah
okay beautiful we love it we absolutely
love it all right let's get back over to
the Washington Post video here and get
back to your comments via superjet
bailey RN said oh sorry Michelle Bennett
no I skipped a whole bunch and I
apologize
Jason Pope says oh no we already did
that one first-class admiral Giga Chad
says your take on a Biden Bernie ticket
won't happen though my take is it won't
happen that's exactly right
lies in politics says do you think Biden
can beat Trump I believe Biden can beat
Trump and I believe Biden can can can
lose the Trump as well
Paul McLaughlin sends a super chap
Michael Bennett's has voted for Bernie
in Washington State Michelle Bennett
sorry no regrets
Bailey RN says how is it that Biden is
viewed as electable he has major
skeletons cognitive concerns and no
message it's as if they want more Trump
that is a very popular view among many
on the left Alex since Iraq says would
you vote for Trump over Kim jong-un if
in an alternative alternative universe
where it was either him or Trump for
president I probably vote for Trump /
Kim jong-un
yes that that's true casual Thursday
says David would you shush a woman
during an argument
ah okay I have no idea what you're
talking about
and I don't know that I shush people on
the basis of whether they deserve to be
judged
I don't evaluate identity first and you
know whatever but it's I think that you
you've been doing a lot of trolling
tonight so I'm not gonna go overly crazy
in overthinking my my answers to you we
still have no data although we want data
from Idaho and North Dakota and we are
expecting Washington numbers we may have
Washington numbers almost instantly
eleven because people have been voting
my mail for a while so that is that is
that is very very important to bear in
mind about Washington I am going to do
let's see we're gonna do updates at the
bottom of the hour
let's get I oh I do want to get an
update on the popular vote totals Biden
has now surged to a 1.2 million vote
lead over Bernie Sanders and consider I
mean really consider the scope of that
okay
the entire country voted in 2016 for
president and Hillary had a margin of
2.8 million and it was considered
absolutely massive massive massive
massive for a presidential race where
the person with more votes loses this is
a primary we're only about half to
two-thirds have voted so far and Biden
has a 1.2 million vote lead this is
really big and this is why I don't think
it's smart or accurate for the left to
say the establishment stole it because a
1.2 million vote margin already is a
very big popular vote margin for Joe
Biden it's the reality the Bernie voters
didn't show up and there weren't as many
of them as it might have seemed from you
know looking at rally gue crowd sizes
and and the like that it's a it's these
are lessons that we are learning let me
say thank you and welcome to re lore ari
lore is new member number 31 tonight I
also want to say thank you and welcome
to Jordan Blevins Jordan Blevins is new
member number 32 tonight at join
pakman.com that puts us well over a
third of the way to our goal of 89 new
members tonight let's see
rikes banner schwartz wrought gold sends
a super chat that's a mouthful pyro
plasma says do you support the draft by
the way what on earth is happening on
the screen right now number of people
that went from hillary clinton to joe
biden and we do that for each of the
candidates and we set that equal to like
i said the number of votes that joe
biden god and we then rewrite this
equation next we rewrite this equation
basically like this
we say that the number of votes for Joe
Biden is equal to the parameters that I
just defined times the number of votes
that we're out in 2016 and then we do
what we always do in math we solve for x
you know let me it sounds so much easier
with you oh my goodness what is
happening this has been taken over by
math and data okay
pyro plasma says do you support the
draft so listen I I don't support the
draft I sometimes think if we had one
maybe our elected officials would be
more careful about deploying the
military right Jackson says to fellow
progressives just because you don't
agree with Biden's message doesn't mean
he lacks one lots of people are
moderates memorize that fact Joe kracken
Byrd says make Biden stand up get it
trending we're waiting for Joe right now
we will see if he stands during today's
statement and maybe they're about to go
to it let's take a look algebra will be
in my back pocket appreciated Jeremy
thanks so much let's talk a little bit
about endorsements and the sort of
getting on the bandwagon moment that's
been happening ok nothing yet all right
Dave David Adams says Biden hushed and
female aide today that's why they asked
ok I did not I didn't I didn't see that
but I will look it up and certainly I
want to see what it said ok jelly bean
says via twitch Prime subscription hey
everybody on twitch appreciate you guys
jelly bean says I voted for Bernie today
in Washington State thanks for having a
live stream tonight I love hearing your
perspective I also want to say thanks to
mr. Jones who subscribed on Twitch
Daniel 84 has also subscribed on Twitch
and Dominic lob is new member number 33
tonight at join pakman.com which I
appreciate let's listen to our buddy
Dave why gulp friend of mine and that's
that's not that's not him spinning I
mean everything we've learned from
Sanders that he really does like Joe
Biden even though they were at
loggerheads on a lot of stuff he has not
taken swings at Joe Biden that even
people like Michael Bennett did and
Carla Harris did in in the when the
field was more crowded and so as he
figures out whether it is worth
continuing in the race or not he does
not he does not like the idea of being
once again a kind of a gadfly senator in
opposition
often voting against a president but he
is not I think as constitutionally
object objected to the idea of President
Joe Biden as he is as he was with
Hillary Clinton as he was instead
bringing that wing of the party back
into power James would have been the
most powerful endorsements that that Joe
Biden's got we've got Dave Wiggles radar
Dave legal has retweeted me and a whole
bunch of other Washington Post people
this is so funny
Glenn Kessler from The Washington Post
has now retweeted me talking about Dave
Weigel The Washington Post
video producers that are producing the
stream have retweeted me we love those
guys over there we don't call them the
Amazon Jeff Bezos fake news Washington
Post we actually really respect a lot of
the great investigative work that the
Washington Post has been doing and it's
it's been great having a little bit of
their coverage with us as we look at the
results come in where we still have
nothing from North Dakota Idaho or
Washington but we have more and more
from Mississippi which is just a brutal
blowout by Joseph R Biden Jr Missouri a
very strong win for Joe Biden exceeding
the polling expectations so Missouri
Biden right now is 25
where was he polling in Missouri he was
polling Oh actually no Biden
underperforming in Missouri Biden was
actually polling +30 in Missouri hard to
keep all the numbers straight Biden was
polling plus 30 in Missouri but ended up
only plus 25 as of right now so actually
an under performance for Biden there and
then Michigan Biden plus 14 right now
plus 14 in Michigan okay oh we have
North Dakota numbers and with 10 percent
reporting Bernie Sanders has hopped up
to a 13.5 percent lead somehow Elizabeth
Warren still has 13 percent there I
don't know if this is that this is I
believe a firehouse caucus and maybe
that's why or maybe we will get some
explanation about that momentarily but
that is what we have so far
out of out of North Dakota let's see if
we have any North Dakota stuff so far
from Vox it doesn't look like we do know
nothing from Vox yet but some early
numbers with ten percent reporting from
North Dakota they're very very exciting
okay other super chats that are coming
in let's see here okay smack alpaca
says how do you think this election will
affect 2024 we won't know until we know
the outcome of this election and we have
to think about 2022 how do you think a
Biden Trump debate would go I think it
would be far less eventful than a lot of
people imagined harsh all Parmar says
how long before someone truly
progressive becomes president it's gonna
be a little while it's gonna be a little
while little solace says voting green in
California let's watch it burn rikes
banner Schwartz wrought gold says Tulsi
still in because of Corona kills the old
people you're not the first person to
mention that very very dark and grim
joke rockin Berg says Joe Biden will
vote for Trump because they'll forget
whether he's Trump or Biden Bernie 2020
mark Huff tling says you are an
important voice David keep up the great
work thank you mark and I recognize your
name I know you've been supporting the
show for a while and I really appreciate
that I also want to say thanks to Devin
Hodgson Devin is a new subscriber 34
tonight at join pakman.com number 34
consider grabbing a subscription at join
pakman.com
but if you want to not pay anything
which I totally respect if you're
watching on YouTube give us a like we
are almost at 2,000 likes on YouTube for
the stream hit the subscribe button
would love that if you're watching on
Twitch make sure to follow if you have
Amazon Prime you can get a twitch Prime
subscription for free and we do now have
numbers coming in from North Dakota with
10 percent reporting Bernie Sanders is
up 13 there and maybe would be able to
get a win North Dakota somewhere between
four is at 14 at one of these Idaho and
North Dakota
14 and 20 delegates each I just don't
remember offhand which is which but we
we will know that very very soon
Oh Delton delegate numbers yes people
wanted a delegate update the lead for
Joe Biden now is 783 to 627 that looks
like 156 to me is that right
151 five six yeah a hundred and fifty
six delegate lead now for Joseph R Biden
Jr over Bernie Sanders in the Democratic
primary so far I am being told
Idaho now has 20 percent reporting
anybody is that right oh I'm sorry
Idaho is 20 delegates right I apologize
got confused there okay let's see what's
happening over on PBS briefly gonna do a
water refill the last one of the night
and then we will be back including with
Washington results just moments from now
where I start talking about going
through the primaries into things like
the conventions and then of course
voting in November yeah and you
mentioned turnout want to get to that
but just very quickly again on this
corner virus I can it's like to turn
this into a moment about crises and how
you handle them that's what they do that
you know you find a way to just sort of
focus on your strengths we've seen this
both from Sanders and Biden who have
said look at the way that President
Trump was handling this and that the way
he's mishandling it they argue we would
do it differently is that the type of
message you think that resonates with
voters or do they say well this is an
isolated case I'm not willing to judge
the president just on this one thing
yeah we don't know quite yet I mean I
think the jury is still out the initial
polling about this but specifically the
question of how do people feel Donald
Trump is doing on this not surprisingly
it's breaking down harder lines right
Republicans think he's doing great
Democrats think he's doing terribly but
I do think that as we move through this
process it is going to be a very
important moment of leadership
believability all of those sorts of
things and look we may think we know how
people are processing the
today but then as we fast forward into
the fall how they processed it at the
time may not still be with them the
interesting thing to think about Daniels
these last four years how many big major
what would be game-changing political
landscape altering events have happened
hmm and nothing has really moved
anybody's numbers right whether it's the
president's numbers opinions about
candidates you know it's been really
stable is this the thing that finally
does start to sort of break us out of
this partisanship and I guess the next
question to is it's not just about the
president it is how is Congress handling
it
how are health officials in these states
handling it governor's lot of these are
mayors and governors who have to make
these moment-by-moment decisions so this
it could have ripple effects that go far
beyond just this 20/20 raise that's such
a good point one of them you'd mentioned
was turnout and we're still waiting to
see what these final turnout numbers
will be tonight but we do know this just
last week Super Tuesday a big moment for
the campaigns and the turnout was was
astounding I mean you had Virginia for
example up almost half a million voters
Texas up 1.4 million voters a lot of
states saw these are Democrats now
coming out in high numbers compared to
2016 the question I think we're all
asking in this moment is is this a surge
for Joe Biden that suddenly voters who
might have had misgivings phone love
with him or is this a sign of how much
Democrats want to beat Donald Trump I
would go for the a sign of how much the
Democrats want to beat Donald Trump
that's not to say that Joe Biden's not
popular in fact both Joe Biden and
Bernie Sanders are well liked this isn't
about coming out to show how much you
don't like one of the Democratic
candidates or how much you do like one
of the other Democratic candidates it's
not as simple as that
but I do think that the most important
person in this primary is Donald Trump
the the feelings that Democrats have
that beating him are so intense in fact
I was just scrolling through before I
came up here the 2016 exit polls in
Michigan when the asked voters you know
what what is important value to you for
these candidates that they you know are
left a bowl that they care about people
like me that they have leadership
qualities only 17% said electability was
an important issue for them that is now
up to 70 credit differences yeah
interesting we were just talking about
of comparing there's a little bit to
2004 in some ways a similar election no
elections are exactly like but a moment
in time where there was a sitting
Republican president running for
re-election that Democrats really did
not like they nominated a candidate in
John Kerry who they saw as a safer
choice someone who was more electable
someone who represented the Democratic
establishment it was a question then as
it is now how much is this support for
Kerry versus beating bush a lot of
Democrats I think underestimated Bush in
his campaign they ran a very good
campaign in 2004 how does that moment
compare in time to to this one that
we're looking at now going forward I do
think that the intensity factor is that
much stronger today than it was in 2004
year exactly right when there's an
incumbent president especially a
president who's been incumbent this
would be obviously his his reelection
the intensity factor among the out party
to get rid of that person is really high
so it's let's all you know circle around
our one candidate as early as possible
to give that person all the advantages
that we can and make a safe
quote-unquote safe pick the difference
this year and we're seeing it in these
to go back to your turnout numbers in a
way that we didn't in 2004 what we're
seeing are people turning out and voting
in these primaries who stayed home in
2016 at least at the primary stage or
maybe they hadn't been registered to
vote or hadn't you know just been
engaged in the in in politics we've been
we've been seeing this pattern since
Donald Trump was elected in 2017 in
Virginia you had record turnout for
state legislative race yes it's not that
voters and Virginia all the son got
interested in what's going on in
Richmond they wanted they felt sort of
helpless after the election and
Democratic voters said what can I do
about it all right well let's just start
voting for people with D after their
name and that continued into 2018 where
Democrats won control of the house and
it is continuing to spill over the real
question is going to be how many of
these voters who are turning out now are
new to the Democratic Party that
Democrats can count on them to show up
in November and maybe they were voters
in 2016 that voted for a third party
candidate or that Donald Trump will they
come and and support Joe Biden if he's
the nominee
yeah and lastly Amy you know to your
point about how the most important
person in this race is going to be
Donald Trump the president let's end
there and my question to you is we've
seen Trump do some interesting things he
is going to states where Democrats have
debates and campaigning the day before
sometimes the day of we saw that in
South Carolina we saw that in New
Hampshire I believe he is getting his
surrogates out there he's obviously on
the offensive on social media how
different is this approach to incumbents
in the past right committee it say
there's a trolling component in here
right wherever the Democrats are that's
where the president is going to be but I
think it's it's also a very interesting
strategy by the president because what
he's saying is I'm not conceding a
moment or a vote to Democrats and I'm
going to be able to show you that just
my very presence he's going to be able
to turn out those Republicans this is
not gonna be a complacent electorate I
am back and we are now in the final
stretch they are talking about Florida
which is going to be essentially a
complete firewall for Bernie Sanders and
it's a lot of the reason why it was do
or die today for Bernie as it is because
Bernie's going to get absolutely crushed
in Florida unfortunately for him a lot
of Florida Democrats are just not not
really into the
the Bernie ideology and we've we've
known that for some time Bernie was
always going to have to do well
elsewhere Florida is not going to be the
place for Bernie Sanders okay let's get
to some other questions here
Peter Jeon Papa has signed up for a
YouTube membership at the SOI boy level
thank you Peter Jorge Luis says David
can I ask you if you're an LGBT
individual some of us would love that I
am NOT I am an ally you can check out if
you want to have a if you want to see
something really fun
excuse me go to my Wikipedia page look
at the history on it and look at the
number of times that there have been
fights trying to say that I am a gay man
and then it gets changed back and you
see notes saying no he said he's an ally
and somebody says no he's clearly gay
look at his hair somebody changed my
name on Wikipedia to David gay Pakman
which actually I found kind of funny but
I am NOT a member I am an ally my friend
Kevin Villalobos Gonzalez as is a vote
for Biden a vote for the Obama era well
he wants us to see it that way by
calling himself an obama/biden democrat
or a no Biden Bhama Democrat as he once
said Luke says David why are you calling
it quits for Sanders Sam cedar says more
of the delegates up for grabs after
today and we have Sunday's debate to
debut to the public
Biden's dementia everybody can call it
the way they see it Michelle Bennett
says Washington state ballots ballots
had to be postmarked by today ah so they
will continue to trickle in Trey Adkins
says voted Biden in Texas as an
anti-trump libertarian independent go
open primaries
do you agree a Biden Trump general will
have better independent moderate turnout
I've not thought about that and I don't
know I would have to think about that
David Kaye says are you gonna say I told
you so and rub it in the moderate
Democrats face when they lose the Trump
in November like you are with Bernie
supporters I'm not rubbing anything in
anyone's face when I'm wrong about
something I tell you I'm wrong I
predicted from put lose in November of
2016 I was wrong and I've been clear
about that I
said a week ago Bernie has no path and
today's results reinforce it dad that's
it I mean I don't know about you no
rubbing anything in people's faces not
not even sure I totally even understand
okay let's see what updated results we
may or may not have coming in North
Dakota still just 10 percent reporting
very very light out of North Dakota
nothing out of Idaho although polls
closed 37 minutes ago and we are waiting
on Washington at the top of the hour and
we will see in terms of the popular vote
Joe Biden is now leading the popular
vote over Bernie Sanders by one and a
quarter million votes that just keeps
expanding and we may have by the end of
the primary if things don't reverse we
may have a 2 million vote lead guys
people saying it's not 10:00 p.m. in
Idaho I understand that 10:00 p.m.
Eastern Time polls closed at 10:00 p.m.
eastern time as it says on the screen so
I understand time zones I appreciate the
concern I'm okay
lela um Josephus says glad the United
States is turning into a dictatorship we
earned it Republicans are turning us
into an oligarchy but we deserve it
Scott Schoenberg says top of the mornin
to ya it's me o Biden Joe Biden Oh Biden
Bhama I kind of like the sound of that
to be perfectly frank I don't uh I don't
dislike it at all if you're just joining
us welcome on Twitch Facebook and
YouTube it has not been a great night
for Bernie Sanders so far Bernie Sanders
has lost Mississippi by roughly 65
points has lost Missouri by roughly 27
points that's actually getting closer to
exactly what the polls said and has lost
Michigan so far by 14 points but there
are still votes to cast we have 10%
reporting from North Dakota where Bernie
Sanders is indeed ahead Elizabeth Warren
with twelve point eight percent of the
vote so far we are waiting on results
from Idaho and at the top of the hour we
will start getting some results from
Washington it will be I mean because we
have very few things
left here that are still question marks
okay zoom that in a little bit let me
see there we go we will be interested to
see whether in Washington they are able
to call it right at 11:00 or whether it
will be too close to call the Washington
polling as of this morning had Biden up
in every poll done in March
Biden plus one Biden plus three and
Biden plus six but conceivably it is one
where Bernie could at least be
competitive so far not competitive in
any of the ones that have been called
but if you're if you're joining me I
also want to point out that III called
the entire thing over an hour and a half
ago when Michigan was called I said it's
over so I know that there's people
saying David can you stop this like it's
over it's over
why aren't you saying it's over I said
it's over a long time ago I said it's
over at must have been what was it 845
or 9:15 or something like that I
understand what's going on my friends I
understand what's going on okay let me
say thank you and welcome to Joshua
Rosales Joshua Rosales is new member
number 35 tonight we do have this thing
called membership I know you've probably
never heard of it because I never
mention it we are looking to get 89 new
members why 89 beautiful question Super
Tuesday we had 88 people sign up on my
website we're just trying to beat that
by one why not right we'll just pick
that you can sign up at join pakman.com
coupon code 2020 now saves you 66
percent the goal is 89 solon aureus says
voted Bernie in California David what do
you think it would take to actually
enact rank-choice voting at both the
primary and general elections that's
gonna be more of a state issue I think
we need to be doing it at the state
level Maine did it we need to be turning
state houses state legislatures and
state Senate's and working through it
that way rather than waiting for some
kind of national ranked choice or single
transferable vote thing because I think
that that's a very uphill battle
let me say thank you over on Twitch 2cm
493 cm 493 has subscribed with twitch
Prime and I I appreciate that very very
much we are starting to get results from
North Dakota if you're joining us we are
waiting for results from Idaho which
closed 41 minutes ago and we are just 19
minutes from Washington closing people
have been mailing ballots in and voting
in person today and ballots have to be
postmarked by today to count so there
will be a couple more days where they
will continue to trickle in and we will
see whether that plays a role in
ultimately who is the winner we will
also see whether they are able to call
it right at 11:00 or not and that that
will be something we will be following
as well let's see if we have anything we
are all we are also waiting for Joe
Biden he was scheduled to speak an hour
and 12 minutes ago Biden apparently
known for being late I didn't know that
but it is
I guess he's known for being late and he
is running very very late today
and we will see how much longer we have
to wait for Joe Biden statements I am
curious to hear him the latest delegate
count let me refresh and make sure we're
up-to-date yes it is 156 Bernie Sanders
is now down 156 delegates to Joe Biden
and depending on what happens the rest
of the night that may increase or it may
not we still have just 10 percent
reporting in North Dakota importantly
consider that in Mississippi Bernie
Sanders is almost not viable at 15.2%
and that could be something that takes
place that that is relevant as the
delegate numbers continue to accumulate
and add up we will certainly be
following that as well over via super
chat capricious Capricorn says hi my
name is Timmy I'm 10 I used parent's
credit card ha ha Wow Timmy that is that
is wild Vasile a Vonda says David what
can we
to motivate young voters I wish I knew
young voters didn't turn up this
election and they were Bernie Sanders
was counting on them and did I I at this
point I don't know what it takes to get
young voters to go out and vote it's
easy to get them to say oh I like this
candidate over that candidate that's
pretty easy it's get it's easy to get
them to know about the candidates not as
easy to get them to actually go out and
vote
Adar Aidan van has subscribed on Twitch
with the message David I love you bubby
please please spend more time on Twitch
you and Steven Bunnell ii have the
greatest chemistry in the world remember
that Steven Kenneth destiny bunnell the
second okay Bailey RN asks will a OC run
in the future no idea not worried about
it right now
mr. Daughtry says did we lose Biden VP
guess
Bernie lost and Biden I I think it's
gonna be Kamala or Amy Kamala or Amy
running with Biden Gregory Bertrand says
Biden got the black vote so he thinks he
can run on CP time that's horrible I
don't like that at all I mean okay I
guess that's pretty vile should I delete
that or should we leave that up like is
that just a funny joke or are people
offended I find it pretty pretty
horrible so they're like should that be
deleted because it's a racist deleted
okay all right we're gonna delete that
let's see
remove okay cool message deleted now
what's fascinating is there's no way to
refund super chat so we do keep the
money when people send stuff like that
remember that crazy thing I don't know
how many of you guys were with me back
when we were doing the impeachment
streams but there was during one of the
big impeachment streams somebody sent
multiple anti-semitic super chats in a
row and we just deleted them and
somebody spent like 50 bucks sending me
anti-semitic messages which were almost
instantly deleted but we kept the money
because there's no refund function it
was wild it was very very crazy okay
let's take a bit of a listen to what is
happening here on Washington Post
coverage
voters out who do want to see change who
who want to see a serious pivot away
from the Trump years to maybe a return
or maybe something brand-new so how do
they walk that line of saying let's go
back to something reassuring but also
let me give you something to get very
excited about yeah that's right now
they're leaning more on the form they're
kind of saying we're gonna return to the
Obama era but he's he he also frames at
his son of a decency check at dignity
check character you know no one no one
thinks he's gonna be more of Trump he
kind of talks about restoring honor to
the office let's see all right nothing
too surprising happening here let's see
here Alexa Cameron says if you're a
person of color colored people time is a
household joke okay Dinobot says why are
people who have dropped out still left
on ballots shouldn't they be removed
from ballast if they end their candidacy
it does not actually work that way Brad
sir daddy says Donald Trump won tonight
this is depressing there is there is a
sort of lack of energy for sure let me
say thank you and welcome to Brandon
Richardson who is new member number 36
tonight that's 3 6 3 6 love it thank you
so much Brandon you can sign up and join
Brandon at join pakman.com it's quick
it's easy it takes a second ok
let me see here there's a user who just
signed up on twitch and now I'm gonna
have to figure out the right way to say
this ok Jimmy Khun alingas has signed up
on Twitch prime ok Thank You Adrian
benningfield says call the deleted
messages conservative taxes David yes
that's certainly an idea it's certainly
something that the way we could refer to
them I also want to welcome Michael
Sylvia Michael Sylvia is new member
number 37 tonight 3:7 thanks Michael
very much appreciate that we are waiting
on what are we waiting on right now we
whoa we have a hypetrain on Twitch we
got to level 3 before let's get to level
5 3 5 3 5 let's get to level 5 it's
happening ok we are waiting on Joe Biden
to speak he was scheduled
to speak an hour and 18 minutes ago
still has not spoken we don't know why
we are waiting on more extensive North
Dakota results currently only 10%
reporting we are aiding on Ida waiting
on Idaho reports we it has been closed
for 48 minutes there still no
information and we are waiting on the
top of the hour closure in Washington
State
12 minutes away 12 minutes away they're
looking at delegate numbers Bernie
Sanders is trailing by 150 55 delegates
155 now that is where those numbers are
and Joe Biden has surged to a 1.3
million vote lead in the popular vote as
well is this seems to be updated in very
much real time 1.3 1 0 see if I hit
refresh 1.3 1 - wow that is being
updated very very quickly so those are
all of the different things that we are
currently waiting on and we are we don't
know why Biden has not spoken yet autumn
OC says is Biden still going to speak
tonight thanks for doing what you do as
far as I know he is going to speak we're
talking about it oh let's see if they're
gonna go - I think so let's go live now
- here we go it's remarks our
headquarters is just around the corner
and these are all people working like
the devil to try to get a selected as
I thank my sister Valerie and my
son-in-law dr. Howard crime were here
and folks look we were planning a big
rally in Cleveland tonight but the
governor of Ohio asked the presidential
campaigns to cancel their indoor public
events in Cleveland worth large large
crowds of people and that's what we did
due to the corona virus and he was
concerned about that and as I've said
all along that we would follow the
guidance of the CDC state local
officials and public health officials
with respect to our campaign events
we'll continue to do that this is a
matter
this whole corona virus this was a
matter of presidential leadership and
later this week I'll be speaking to you
on what I believe the nation should be
doing to address this virus but tonight
I want to speak to you from Philadelphia
where we announced our campaign at the
front end where we did our final
announcement to all those who have been
knocked down all those have been counted
out left behind this is your campaign
just over a week ago many of the pundits
declared that this candidacy was dead
now we're very much alive
[Applause]
and although although there's a way to
go it looks like we're gonna have
another good night yes indeed that's
better school Michigan and we're waiting
to hear from North Dakota Idaho and
Washington State as I said from the
beginning this election is the one that
has character on the ballot the
character the candidates the character
the nation is on the ballot it's more
than a comeback in my view our campaign
it's a comeback for the soul of this
nation this campaign is taking off and I
believe we're gonna do well from this
point on yeah joe said Missouri and he's
not from Missouri so maybe it's not so
offensive by the way thank you - turkey
bacon and cheese for gifting 20 subs and
getting us to hypetrain level 5 also
Chloe vaasi participating Astro knight
and Izzy wicked volunteer and contribute
if you can we need you we want you
there's a place in our campaign for each
of you and I want to thank Bernie
Sanders and his supporters for their
tireless energy and their passion we
share a common goal this is like a wrap
up speech for Bernie than fighting as
Donald Trump will defeat amigo
the various Haitian together we're
regenerating a Democratic base the
Democratic Party the african-american
community high school educated folks
like the ones I grew up with in Claymont
not far from here in my old neighborhood
labor suburban women veterans
firefighters union members who so many
more people of every economic station
the poor who are struggling and they are
struggling in this environment the
middle class worries about whether or
not they're gonna be able to hang on and
stay there
maintain the Economic Security they're
the reason Jill and I got involved this
in this campaign in the first place and
they're the reason why I became a
Democrat so long ago and I can't tell
you I really mean there's some bottom my
heart I can't tell you how much I
appreciate the confidence they've shown
in me thus far and the way they turned
out to vote for me my first campaign
when I was a kid a long time ago I had a
billboard that said one thing on it had
a picture my wife and children and it
said for all our families that's all it
was for all our families that included
Democratic families families of
independent voters Republican families
everyone of every stripe for all our
families and look that's where we're
able to accomplish in South Carolina
that's what we did on Super Tuesday and
it appears almost a little premature it
appears that's we're able to do tonight
for just the past week so many my
incredibly capable competitors have
endorsed me mayor Pete Buda jizz Amy
Klobuchar better O'Rourke Mike Bloomberg
Cory Booker and Komal Harris doesn't
seem to matter to me
together we're bringing this party
together that's what we have to do
tonight we are a step closer to
restoring decency dignity and honor to
the White House that's our ultimate goal
I kinda like we're being picked up by
the mic at this moment there's so much
fear in the country there's so much fear
across the world we need American
leadership we need presidential
leadership that's honest trusted
truthful and steady reassuring
leadership if I'm given the honor of
becoming your president I promise you
I'll strive to give the nation that very
leadership every day every day I have a
privilege the whole office that's the
reason why I'm running for president I
believe we're at an incredible moment in
American history a phenomenal
opportunity to deliver a bowl
progressive vision to the American
people guaranteeing that every American
has health care affordable health care
total health care not of trivial disease
even using a time for
building on Obamacare providing every
child access to good education
regardless of their zip code to deal
with the moral depravity of our children
who have to learn as they go to school
little children - ducking covers zigzag
down the hallway because they fear
someone with a semi-automatic weapon
maybe coming in we have to stand up for
the gun manufacturers and to the NRA we
build the middle class we have to
rebuild alone class this time bring
everybody alone everybody
my fellow Americans we have to once
again lead the world Donald Trump's
America first policies made America
alone you know and the fight against
climate change we have to rally the rest
of the world to act and act now rejoin
the Paris climate Accord on day one make
it clear to our allies that will honor
our commitments that our word can be
trusted
and make clear to our adversaries oh
he's going around and restoring World
Order that's the American responsibility
tonight
I'm speaking you from the National
Constitution Center not far from where
two of the most important documents in
all of history were written the
Declaration of Independence we hold
these truths to be self-evident those
words became the American creed known
around the world the US Constitution We
the People these words literally changed
the world
we've never fully lived up to the
promise of either those documents but
we've never ever before walked away from
them they're a reminder of what's at
stake in this election our very
democracy is at stake in this election
they said from the moment I announced
not far from here but I believe we're in
the battle for the soul of this nation
with Donald Trump as president our core
values our standing in the world our
very democracy everything that has made
America America is truly at stake I
believe this nation can overcome four
years of Donald Trump and given eight
four more years and forever and
fundamentally changed the very character
this nation we can't let that happen
but winning means but win he means
uniting America not sowing more division
and anger means having the president not
only knows how to fight but knows how to
heal means replacing the president
who'da means and demonizes people with
the president who believes in empathy
compassion respect for everyone
there's my hope that the days of
divisiveness will soon be over
we're a decent brave resilient people we
are better than this moment we're in and
we just what we have to do we just need
we just need to remember who we are this
is the United States of America there's
not a single thing we cannot do if we do
it together wrong close to the eve of
st. Patrick's Day
I'm thought of a quote some of you heard
me quote many times a fella that I
admired very much had passed away not
long ago a poet named Seamus Heaney he
wrote a poem called the cure toy here's
what he said in one stands he said
history teaches us not the hope on this
side of the grave but then once in a
lifetime that long for tidal wave of
justice rises up and hope and history
rhyme
I truly believe it's real our power for
the first time in a long time because of
what's happened in the past three years
the power to make hope and history rhyme
that's what we're gonna do
god bless you all Wow
what a night
[Applause]
what an evening Joe Biden and his wife
dr. Jill Biden addressing a small group
of supporters in Philadelphia stay tuned
we'll be right back
all right we are going to get updated
numbers we do have a little more coming
in edge Intel we have a little coming in
from North Dakota
we now oh no North Dakota still shows
10% here but I saw other numbers let's
see here this one shows zero let me see
if I can find nationwide results here
let's see okay zero report interesting
okay now so maybe we don't have anything
more than the price I could have sworn I
saw a little bit more and it showed that
Biden had actually taken the lead we are
just minutes now from Idaho and
Washington numbers we are standing by
for those numbers no updates yet from
PBS nor the Washington Post let me thank
a whole bunch of new people over on
Twitch note by Joe they dream fatigue
and big iron by Marty Robbins have all
subscribed with twitch prime over on my
website a whole bunch of people have
signed up I want to say thanks to Ian
Barry who is new member number 38
tonight and Brad Erickson who is new
member number 39 tonight thank you so
much you can grab a membership yourself
at join pakman.com let's see if we have
new results are closed you're watching
live coverage of the Washington Post
here on primary night I'm Libby Casey
let's take a look at the big picture
from tonight's races
Joe Biden has won three of the six
states up for grabs tonight Michigan
Mississippi and Missouri early results
are coming in from Idaho where Sanders
has a lead with less than 10 percent
that's not what that says it's his bike
and in North Dakota Sanders has a lead
with less than 10 percent of results
that also says these numbers wrong now's
a good time to check back in with our
election insights team led by the posts
anybody else find that weird she said
Sanders has a lead in both and Biden had
a lead in both based on the numbers they
had on the screen that was
extraordinarily weird and it looked like
the numbers were exactly the same for
both yeah that was that was weird very
odd very very odd also thanks to big
ayran by Marty Robbins for gifting a sub
to Professor knee robot I like that as
well so look this this is Idaho and
Biden votes are basically showing us
places where because there aren't a lot
of voters they can count really quickly
examples like this would be Clark County
which has about 900 residents and there
are exactly six voters here in the
Democratic primary yeah it's a high
we've got you know Biden at 37% Sanders
at 37% and Tulsi Gabbard in there as
well you know we're looking at places
like this in Idaho but again it's likely
to be the case that as Boise in places
like Pocatello and Idaho Falls come in
this might be a place where Sanders can
do well and so then we're gonna be
looking for tonight is to see if he can
hold on to any support this is a state
where we expect him to do you know
better than he's been doing in other
places tonight but for the Biden
campaign if they can't win the state
they at least want to be close now let's
also talk about Washington State I just
mentioned earlier you know mail-in
ballot deadline is now passed here in
Washington State and we expect to see
some results soon this is one of those
states where we expect to see you know
the Sanders campaign all right so no
results yet there although we are we we
are waiting let's see the latest update
here from the New York Times final polls
of the night are about to close but we
do not as of yet have anything out of
there oh I do want to do another check
of the popular vote and Joe Biden is
rapidly heading towards a 1.4 million
vote lead one point four million votes
that is the direction that that is going
in okay
over on YouTube I have a bunch of super
chats coming in that I want to get to
let's see
okay so Biden spoke Dominic Richardson
says I support Bernie but were there any
of Warren's positions that were better
than Bernie's well none of but of
Warren's positions were to the left of
Bernie's the art the debate so to speak
is whether some of Warren's ideas are
more likely to become the law than some
of Bernie's clever to swear says I'm
genuinely shocked at the rise of online
political pundits adopting the Bernie or
bust mentality I'm surprised Trump is no
longer enemy number one it is surprising
Ryan Henry Dean says Biden should give
calm speeches it's more powerful agree
cat purple says Biden is Hillary 2.0 or
Trump 2.5 will do everything Trump or
Hillary but with sad demented Uncle Joe
charisma what is the difference between
Biden or Trump on politics obviously
Biden can't use Twitter listen I just
put a tweet out about this and if you
guys agree with me I would like you to
retweet this okay I just tweeted
basically everything I think I need to
say Wow and 64 people already did
retweet it I said so listen there's no
doubt that Biden isn't a progressive but
I want him not Trump choosing Ruth Bader
Ginsburg replacement his climate plan is
better than Trump's and his health care
plan is milquetoast but it's better than
what Trump wants to do there's little
else to say in my mind that is not a
Bernie or bust mentality right if you
don't like this then come insult me and
ratio me or do whatever it is that you
want to do but if this makes sense to
you then then please do you know
whatever people do on Twitter like it
retweet it I guess retweet is the best
right we're signal boosting and this is
my perspective and I'm going to be
saying more about this tomorrow tomorrow
it's gonna be it's gonna be a long day
night and day still to come we're going
to talk tomorrow about this we're going
to talk about the failings of the Bernie
candidacy I know there are still people
who are going to insist that it's too
early and that I still shouldn't be
talking about this as a as if Bernie
lost but you know okay I mean I
I don't know what it what else to tell
you but that is essentially my
perspective it sounds like that is in
line with some of the things that that
that my followers on YouTube and twitch
are saying right now okay Johnny Silver
Cloud says I'll have to say Biden is
running on the biggest I have a black
best friend flex we will have ever seen
in our lives his black friend in South
Carolina turned the entire thing around
for him
William Henning says Biden was better
tonight he wasn't yelling agree
thanks to de for the super chat clever
to swear says I can already forecast the
videos Biden kind of slurs some words
and is literally dying on stage Bernie
2020
Scott Schoenberg says this speech is the
supercut of flub repairs and ranek
Massey says has signed up on YouTube
Grayson Lane says I'm a college student
who voted Bernie in Texas so many young
people are incredibly apathetic when it
comes to the issues and actively avoid
politics because of the toxicity Paul
Jacobs has become a member on YouTube
Bryan Holaday says Biden can get many
Bernie voters if he can consistently
deliver messages like he just did in
Philly we want to beat Trump just as bad
interesting that is very interesting to
hear from you and I I appreciate I
appreciate you explaining that that is
interesting let's see if we have any I
updated results here we do early numbers
in Idaho with one percent reporting
Joseph R Biden Jr plus 10 over Bernard
Sanders early numbers in Washington with
24 percent reporting Joseph R Biden Jr
plus three over Bernard Sanders let's
compare these results to the polling in
Idaho with very early data Biden is plus
10 let's look at Idaho Democratic
presidential primary Biden was plus four
in the only poll from this month woops
sorry things are clicking all over the
place Biden was plus four in Idaho
currently Biden is plus ten in Idaho but
this is only 1% let's look now at
Washington in Washington
iDEN was roughly i guess if we average
these it's like plus three or four in
washington and so far Biden is plus Oh
it's tied now Washington tied and
Elizabeth Warren because people have
been mailing in ballots for a while
Elizabeth Warren at 12.6% there so this
that could be a fight
if Bernie is going to do well anywhere
tonight I mean North Dakota ok North
Dakota has almost no delegates maybe
Washington is the place where Bernie
could end up pulling some very much
needed delegates although it won't
change the final equation I don't
believe let's listen to our friend Dave
Weigel to manifest it online last couple
days that I think are bit more frantic
and a bit more I guess hard to walk back
then what we've seen before you've seen
frequency the Sanders campaign has been
was trying unearthly failed so far to
make an issue out of Biden's NAFTA vote
or how in the 90s like it like a lot of
Democrats I'm not saying they're right
about this they seem very wrong but that
he was open to some security cuts he's
not any longer but that so there are
some Sanders voters who think that he
just cannot be trusted some who think if
you have a beachhead of left-wing
organizing then you can move him and
Sanders has been moved at other points
the primary on the Hyde Amendment it
took him about 48 hours to go from a
very long held anti-abortion position to
the one the Left held now there's
something has been more resistant on but
you if you start to think about where do
this tonight and I mentioned the online
chatter because you've seen more in the
last 24 hours of what you see on Fox
frankly of questioning whether Biden has
the acuity the sharpness they debate
Trump to go against Trump well here's on
the Biden speech though he says he has a
theory of how to win this election which
is to be fair so we've come for these
races not something that I recognized
from my life covering politics it is and
I bet on how the country is really tired
of having to think about the president
all the time and wouldn't it be nice to
have somebody who looks like a president
in a movie who comes on when there's a
crisis who can talk about it but it's
not constantly holding rallies not
constantly shouting it seemed kind of
reasonable because the recent experience
of Democrats is we is they lose with
Hillary Clinton who couldn't excite
people they win with Barack Obama the
most exciting orator is generate
and the Biden bet was incredibly
different it was that people are really
tired things are when things are bad
they're bad because of the president
when things are good we do that that
cuts against the idea they want a
revolution and that that speech kind of
epitomizes it I think that was how it
was framed was imagined this guy not
doing nothing as president having an
agenda having a Liberty having a
progressive agenda but not in-your-face
at all times yeah we heard him talk
about the coronavirus
we didn't hear brand-new information or
anything else it was once again very
very interesting the way that the
dynamics of this are shaping up we are
starting to get faster arriving numbers
Bernie Sanders has taken a lead now in
Washington with 64% reporting or it's
tied I guess actually bernie is up by 32
votes both at 32.8% that is very
interesting that has reduced Joe Biden's
total popular vote lead it was very
quickly heading towards 1.4 million it
has now shrunk a little bit a little
closer to 1.3 5 million riding on the
backs of these Washington numbers
meanwhile North Dakota stuck at 10% and
in Idaho with 4% reporting
Joseph R Biden Jr still holding at plus
10 that did not diminish when we went
from 1 to 4 percent so that is very very
interesting but these Washington numbers
we are going to be paying extremely
close attention to because it's sort of
the only thing Biden Bernie rather has
going for him at this point in time
there is very little else to be said for
Bernie Sanders really tonight ok super
chats coming in let's see here
morph Cogan says why do you not show
negative emotion for Bernie's failure I
have integrated that Bernie has been
done like 10 days ago so it's just not
news to me I know that there's a lot of
people who were still thinking that
maybe he had a shot I didn't think
Bernie had a shot when Bernie lost South
Carolina by so much I thought Bernie was
done in my head I said it on Super
Tuesday and it's just not news to me you
know I've integrated this for a long
time and I've been saying for a while
you know Bernie's got some really toxic
people around him
I understand that there are people who
like the policies but don't like the
whole milieu look that word up and it's
just none of this is a surprise so it's
hard to feel shocked when when you know
it's it's what I've expected to happen
cat purple says Pakman equals Rossum
move one seat up not to the front okay I
guess you I guess you're saying that I'm
not liberal enough okay let me know what
issue that applies to young dumb and
Baroque says where do you see the
leftist movement after 2020 you
predicted you predicted a Biden loss
would cause the Democratic establishment
to reflect but they seemed too stubborn
to do so well Biden didn't lose yet I
think we won't know the impact until we
see the results of 2020 clever to swear
says now it's Tulsi time watch her sweep
the primaries yes she's just been
sitting back like a cat waiting to
pounce at this exact time Bob B so says
I think everything is just going to go
on even if Donald Trump wins it is what
it is but we need to move on mmm nostril
says what is your perspective on Biden
versus Trump I just tweeted about it and
I invite you if you agree with me to
retweet this it's the latest tweet on my
Twitter account I said there's no doubt
Biden isn't too progressive but I want
him not Trump choosing Ruth Bader
Ginsburg's replacement his climate plan
is better than Trump's and his health
care plan is milquetoast but it's better
than what Trump wants to do there's
little else to say in my mind that's my
view okay if that resonates with you
consider giving me a retweet on that I
would appreciate it okay also-ran says
your friend mentioned voters don't want
shouting do you think Bernie's shouting
style is rooted in the 60s and it
doesn't work as well in the Trump era I
think that's the least of Bernie's
problems quite frankly I don't I mean
maybe there's a style thing there that
you're onto but no I don't think that
that's why Bernie lost at all Scutari
says any California delegate numbers yet
a whole bunch of California delegate
numbers are already in the totals just
not not all of them Dominick Richardson
says is Trump the worst president
in the United States history you know
it's so hard to make blanket statements
like that and I hesitate to do it he's
certainly the worst president of my
lifetime as someone who was old enough
to pay attention to politics Alexa
Cameron says do you think it is
counterproductive for Democrats to
primary in red states first since we
aren't likely to win in the general
there's the the primary system doesn't
make any sense but not for that reason
I've pointed out other reasons why I
think the primary system does not make
any sense whatsoever
let's get updated numbers they are
coming in more quickly now Washington
with 66% reporting dead even dead even a
couple hundred votes separating Bernie
and Joseph R Biden Jr both at 32.7%
now here's the thing folks it almost
doesn't matter now with 66% reporting it
is very unlikely that anybody will win
Washington by a lot and they're gonna
split the delegates that's what it's
gonna be and let's actually see what I
had I'm just finding my woops sorry
about that here it is so I was
predicting that Washington would be
almost even I had a few more delegates
for Biden but again it this is basically
going to be what happens it's not going
to get either of them an advantage in
the sense that if it remains sort of
like this now Bernie with 0.1 percent
lead they will either get the same
number of Delegates or it'll vary by one
or two so really no surprise there
Idaho's still stuck at four percent
North Dakota still stuck at 10 percent
reporting there okay
morph Cogan says off-topic would you
take two hours to watch to watch
Dominion calm I don't know anything
about it I don't know what was just
recommended I can't vouch for it in any
way whatsoever we do have a goal tonight
of 89 new members on my website why our
website members the best we pay the
smallest fee to receive payments there
if you do super chat twitch this that
the other thing someone's taking a slice
and it's a much bigger slice than you
might have mad
when you sign up on our website we just
paid two point nine percent to swipe
credit and debit cards that's why we
encourage website subscriptions and you
can save sixty-six percent with the
coupon code twenty twenty now help get
us closer to this goal of eighty nine
new members help get us closer we are
currently at 39 let's push towards
eighty nine and somebody who is doing
that right now is Cedric or Bond who is
new member number forty at join
pakman.com thanks so much so much Cedric
I very much appreciate that I also want
to say thank you to Baba
DeWitt for the twitch Prime subscription
Mike asks is under estimating Biden's
ability to screw up and tank again wise
I don't wish harm on anyone but who
knows how his mental physical health
will progress should and Bernie stay in
as a contingency sure remember if you
want to do physical health
Bernie 78 and he had a heart attack
months ago so I I think that that that
sort of runs both ways and thanks to Bob
B sews for signing up on YouTube at the
alpha level as well
Dominic Richardson says last question do
you believe Bernie is a social democrat
or a democratic socialist as in no more
capitalism Bernie may in his head be a
socialist his campaign has run on social
democracy so that that's what I go by
Scott Ari says lighter note any garden
plans this year David yes as many of you
know if you follow me on Instagram I had
a garden an urban garden last summer and
I grew a whole bunch of stuff vegetable
you can find videos of me on my
Instagram page in fact I have a separate
playlist on Instagram called urban
garden where you can actually see me
yeah anyway so I I do have big gardening
plans I'm actually gonna start last time
I bought seedlings because I didn't get
started till like May but this time I'm
actually gonna get those indoor it's
almost like ice cube trays you do a
single seed in each one I'm gonna try to
start some seedlings and get a whole
bunch of stuff I'm gonna do Tomatoes
we're gonna
do peppers bunch of different herbs and
and a whole bunch of things I appreciate
the diversion at this crucial moment let
me say thank you and welcome to Antoine
baldessari who is new member number 20
sorry 41 tonight at join pakman.com as
we continue to get closer closer and
closer to more results still just 10% in
North Dakota 6% now in Idaho with Biden
at plus 8 and still 66% in Washington
with Bernie Sanders just in a squeaker
just barely barely ahead but ahead
likely to share a similar number of
Delegates with Joe Biden if those
numbers indeed remain let me say welcome
to Elko Brower for signing up on YouTube
Johnny Silver Cloud says hey Dave when's
the next time you're gonna debate a
conservative no idea whatsoever maybe
soon maybe soon we've we've done many of
those you can find a lot of them on my
youtube channel let me say welcome to
Joshua severs who is new member number
42 tonight thanks Joshua very much
appreciate the support I also want to
say thank you over on Twitch - where the
hell is joiner where the hell is joiner
is the the latest a subscriber there I
am curious what the result what the
answers are what the responses are to my
tweet about listen I think Biden I think
you have to vote for Biden essentially
if it's Biden V Trump let's see some of
the reactions I don't care so that's a
Bernie or buster David's brain is
disintegrating before our eyes he's not
going to be lucid in November okay
I won't stand for the DNC when they've
stolen the election from Bernie twice in
a row so again I don't know that that's
true Biden has almost 1.4 million more
votes than Bernie to say that the DNC
stole it people dropped out and endorsed
by Dhin and and to say that that is the
DNC stealing it seems misguided to me I
don't think we win anything
that type of thing so I mean I guess
there's a mix not voting is saying I
don't care about the outcome Biden would
not be able to take the Senate
sorry not playing didn't matter in 2016
not going to matter in 2020 see this
seems very dumb to me because it was
only because of 77,000 votes in three
states that Trump won in 2016 so
actually it did matter 77,000 votes can
go one way or the other like that so I'm
sort of concerned by some of the
reactions that I'm seeing here it's not
it's not great it's certainly not great
I'm very worried about it Washington is
still at 66% Idaho is now at 11 and
Biden's lead has grown a little bit to
nine point six percent North Dakota
still 10% reporting they're ten percent
reporting okay
Adams W says do you think Bernie should
drop out after tonight no probably not
Bernie can get a bunch of Delegates next
Tuesday and those delegates are a
political capital so III I don't know if
I were Bernie I probably wouldn't drop
out tonight unless I really didn't want
to get crushed in Florida in which case
I would drop out tonight and Stark says
why can't Bernie get the older liberal
vote there's a lot of answers to that
and one of them has to do with the word
socialism see Brooks says convince me
how a neoliberal who was party to the
Iraq war is worse than Trump knowing
what we know now and all of the
suffering again look at my tweet Supreme
Court climate healthcare Biden's not
great but he's better than Trump if you
don't if you don't believe in this idea
of vote for the least bad person then go
into whatever you want right I mean just
it it depends what you want depends what
you value let me say thank you and
welcome to Sean Moriarty who
sorry about that new member number 43
tonight is Shawn Moriarty Jared Teague
nor is new member number 44 thanks Jared
Nancy Pettis is new member number 45 and
then Andrew Rhine vault is new member
number 46 I'm feeling pretty good about
all of those pronunciations I think all
of those went went relatively okay Brad
sir daddy says no one could pay me to
vote for Biden okay I mean that'll help
Trump get reelected you you that's it's
not invalid to say I would rather it be
Trump than Biden I just disagree with
you it's a gentleman's disagreement BJ
blitz says if Trump wins re-election
will any real progressive change be
upheld because of the Supreme Court is
that reason enough to vote Biden I
listed that in my tweet my friends one
of the things I said in what I tweeted
24 minutes ago which I encourage you to
retweet as Wow 213 retweets is already
pretty good the I don't want Trump
choosing Ruth Bader Ginsburg replacement
Ruth Bader Ginsberg's replacement I want
Biden over Trump making that selection
those are the choices I will have I want
Biden making the pick for a Supreme
Court justice that might be on there for
you know decades decades potentially
let's see here what else I missed a few
others here oh nostril says I liked
Bernie not going to lie but I will vote
for Bernie easily against Trump I'm
guessing you mean Biden only a complete
defeatist would drop their vote against
Biden cinema pigeon says idea Biden is
Hillary 2.0 is false since Hillary was
especially hated due to decades of
built-up hate rain yet she still won
millions in the popular vote not in not
wrong robert braun says the people on
Twitter are suffering fresh wounds give
him eight months of listening to Trump
and they'll come around
some of them will not all the dude says
could Bernie in 2016 have thrived on a
sexist vote maybe there really is a huge
section of people who just won't vote
for a woman
I don't know 2016 is done I don't want
to re-litigate me gated Palacios says
good idea for Sanders to run in 2024
Oh No clever to swear says I'm surprised
all the Trump supporters are rebranding
themselves as never buy dinners I have
not seen that Johnny silver cloud says
you can pay me to vote for Biden
however Bloomberg where you at and n
Stark says Bernie got 82 percent of
voters 18 to 29 hashtag crazy
hashtag crazy that is crazy we have
continued numbers coming in nothing new
from North Dakota
Idaho is now up to 15% reporting with
Biden plus seven point for Washington is
67 percent reporting and still very very
close there and that may end up too
close to call if it stays this close
percentage-wise they won't be able to
call it tonight because of all the
ballots that have to be postmarked by
today but won't arrive for several days
let's see how did we end up with the
only candidate that doesn't support
legalizing weed William Henning says
look at crystal balls tweet okay let's
see what crystal tweeted crystal ball
crystal ball says I don't know which one
you want me to look at okay even though
medicare-for-all in G and E are
unpopular voters chose Biden because
they believe they must apiece finicky
moderates progresses and less this can
be endlessly [ __ ] on compared to non
toxic assume who so III just don't know
that I agree I mean again the idea it's
not that people are voting for Biden to
appease moderates the voters are
moderates this is this is the point not
everybody is as progressive as me or is
you in the Democratic Party voters in
northern Florida are not as progressive
as me who vote in the Democratic Party
Missouri Democratic primary voters are
unbalanced on average or not as
progressive as me so I don't believe
that this is the this is the left that
this is voters voting for the moderate
to appease moderates it's moderates
voting for the moderate that's that's
what it is and the policy questions
even when you look at something like
medicare-for-all if you say to people
should the government provide a basic
level of care even if you can't pay for
it very popular 70 75 78 percent people
say that when you start going down and
say okay are you okay with your private
insurance being eliminated and being
forced onto the government program only
about 35% of people want that okay
so it's really important to understand
that a lot of the crux of Medicare for
all which is everybody's got to be able
to get care whether they can afford it
or not it's got to be good care you
can't be able to afford the coverage but
then not the pre not the deductible the
crux of that you have huge agreement
with when you get over to something like
if your plan was simply taken away and
you didn't have the option anymore would
it's much less popular and I think that
that there's an over estimate here when
we say Medicare for all is just popular
it depends what people understand that
to mean and yes exactly
seventy percent want Medicare for all
and seventy percent want to keep private
insurance could not say it better myself
absolutely okay let me see here cat
purple says your tweet response isn't
great because your premise is just
increment incrementalism Hillary
explained how Trump is actually
different than Trump Tim Kaine can you
remind me again who Obama for the
supreme court was was a pro corporate
judge I don't know what you're talking
about cap purple I'm sorry Rory drew
says might be way early to ask this
question but who would be the best
progressive candidate to run in 24 yeah
way too early I have no idea
stupid jerk says what are your views on
Joe Biden and TPP I've we widely on
record
I was against TPP in total although I
thought that there were some minor
things in TPP that would make sense
either standalone or as part of some
other agreement potentially will you use
your info sorry I skipped one Jeff says
Jeff the god of biscuits says Bernie was
doomed when he banked on the demographic
that's least reliable at the polls and
least educated about intra party
politics young
bull BJ blitz says will you use your
influence to help Joe beat Trump I will
try
Samuel C'thun GU says as a moderate
Democrat I can tell you part of it is
the idea amongst Democrats that Bernie
isn't even a real Democrat I don't know
how much that's a factor I don't care
about something like that I'm not even a
Democrat so I that that that's not an
issue for me Alex LaVon EA is new member
number 47 tonight thank you very much
Alex I appreciate that let's look at the
vote counts at this point in time still
stuck at 10% in North Dakota with 17%
reporting in Idaho Biden is now plus 8
and with 66 still in Washington it is
almost a dead heat so that is actually
going to wrap my coverage tonight it is
unlikely we will learn the results of
Washington tonight the other two don't
really matter so we are going to start
bright and early tomorrow with analysis
follow-up and the discussion of what
comes next I really appreciate everybody
who joined me tonight and we will be
back again one week from tonight with
Florida at